the meeting and they can just come in
thank you okay i'm sending you live now
and you'll be ready in 10 seconds
brilliant thanks
okay good evening everybody and welcome
to
the first virtual meeting of stratford
district planning committee in 2021 i
hope you all had a good festive break
and happy new year to
everyone my name is councilor peter
richards and i will be chairing this
evening's meeting
a few housekeepings uh notices if i may
to start with uh first of all uh please
note that the meeting is being live
streamed on
our website youtube and it is being
recorded for publication on the
council's website and youtube at a later
date
members you will all have received the
council's etiquette for virtual meetings
in advance of tonight's meeting however
just to reiterate a few key
points please can you make sure that
your device is
charged to its fullest and preferably
charging
uh if you could mute your microphones
please now and leave them muted
um until you are called to speak of
course you'll need to unmute them
when you speak and then remove them when
you are done if you want to speak
please do indicate in the chat bar
and i will call you at the appropriate
time
if you could also turn off or at the
very least turn to silent any additional
devices you may have in the vicinity
that would also be very helpful if for
any reason you encounter any i.t
problems there are two numbers on our
meeting chat now for you to call
you will have been deemed to have left
the meeting at the point at which you
lose connection if you are unable to
join
but please do make every effort to
rejoin at your earliest
possibility um i can confirm that checks
have been made
in front of our legal officer that all
members of the committee can see and
hear proceedings
and that they have read all papers and
the update sheet that has been confirmed
we do have a number of officers online
with us
tonight from committee services we have
olivia quinn from our
legal services our solicitor is mina
mack we also have
joe brooke aaron weatherston louise
casey and paul thompson who are planners
and will be presenting to us this
evening
and of course our planning manager is
david jeffrey
david i think you've got a statement
you'd like to make yes thank you chair
good evening my name is david jeffrey
i'm the committee manager for tonight's
committee
my role is to provide impartial advice
and to assist members in their decision
taking
thank you marvis thank you very much uh
for members of the public that have
registered to speak
when you are called to speak if you can
please press star
and six on your keypad that will unmute
your phone and we will be able to hear
you
we have had issues um in terms of delay
of hearing
uh what's happening on the committee
that usually occurs when people are
watching online
that is slightly delayed so when it
comes to your item if you could please
listen on the phone rather than watching
online
it will avoid any uh technical issues uh
we also get quite a bit of feedback so
if you if when you do come on
and speak if you could pause or turn off
any live streams that would be also
very helpful um when you are speaking
you'll have three minutes and we will
give you a 30 second warning as
well right let's get into
the main agenda do we have any apologies
please olivia
we've got apologies from councillors
adam and curtis
marvelous thank you very much
disclosures of interest from our members
if you please indicate in the chat if
you have any disclosures of interest to
make
i'll give you a couple of seconds
thank you and good evening and hello to
everybody um
chair i would like to sit back
on the application the application
number is twenty
forward slash zero two four three nine
forward slash
full um through my work at
seconds um i am known to the hughes
family so i think it makes sense if i
just sit back from this particular
application
understood thank you very much i've made
a note of that max as well
thank you chairman um yes application
number nine
twenty zero two eight five six
seventeen oxford street southern on the
ward member
and we'll be speaking on this
i'll be withdrawing from that uh item on
the agenda
lovely thank you that's duly noted and
of course we have councillor mills as
well who's ready to speak
for two questions yeah thank you mr
chairman um
on application uh four on the agenda
uh the land opposite wooden farm
um as i'm the ward member i'll be
sitting out on
the debate on that one and also on
item six on the agenda uh land north of
morton royal lane
once again i am the award member for um
lighthorn so we'll be sitting out on the
debate thank you but i will be speaking
thank you lovely thank you very much
cancer mills um we have no one else
indicating they wish to make a
disclosure so we shall move on
in that case to the minutes can i have a
quick show of hands to confirm that
you're happy with the minutes of our
previous meetings and i'll sign those
our next available opportunity
that is a unanimous display of hands
thank you very much
okay um our uh items for consideration
this evening we are gonna make a slight
change to the running order
um i hope that's okay with everyone we
have two items um
where we have not had any speakers
register
and in the normal course of business
where that happens we can delegate to
offices so first of all if i can bring
forward item eight
which is application reference twenty
zero 2 3
0 1 f u l i propose that we delegate
that
decision to officers could i have a
second
that has been seconded by councillor
jennings i think we do need to take a
roll call
so um uh we'll go straight into that
i'll go first councilor richard's four
uh olivia i think sorry i was muted so
cancer richard
for cancer fleming councillor fleming
four
councillor kendall that's the kendall
four
councillor cramp that's the crump for
councillor jackson
councillor dixon for councillor edin
council reading four thanks to hendra
seraphin
and silencer seraphine for councillor
jennings
council jennings for councillor mills
council mills for parade
councillor parry four unanimous chair
thank you very much uh committee
therefore resolves uh to delegate
decision
for application twenty zero two three
zero one ful jacks orchard in priors
marston
i wasn't very clear with what i said
before originally the parish council had
made an objection they've withdrawn that
uh objection which is why they're no
longer registered to speak by so i'd
make that clear
for everybody watching at home um okay
so also item 10 a similar scenario this
is uh two applications
that we will take on block that is
application twenty zero zero
three nine one ful and twenty zero zero
three nine two
l b c two the green in tai so um i
propose
that we delegate that decision to
officers could i have a second to please
seconded by councillor jennings thank
you very much we'll move straight to a
vote councillor richards
four
cancer flaming four
seraphin
that's unanimous chair thank you very
much olivia
uh committee therefore resolves to
delegate to decision for applications
twenty zero zero three nine one ful
and twenty zero zero three nine two l b
c
that is to the green in so
fabulous right let's go back to the
normal running order then
um which will see us to item four twenty
application twenty zero
one eight four zero out our presenting
officer
is joe brook joe are you there ready to
go
uh thank you chair yes i am let me just
set up the presentation and then we'll
all ready
uh can everybody see that uh
we can um it appears that you've got my
face as a secondary on the screen for
some reason
is
the application site is located on the
eastern edge of kington
as indicated by the black dot before you
the application site lies within the
village accountant with residential
development situated to the north and
west of the applications
the surrounding street scene comprises
of a mix of detached single-story and
two-story dwellings
each set back beyond the front driveway
slash garden depending on which dwelling
with a mix of stone and red brick
finishes
the historic setting of the edge hill
battlefield is 50 meters to the south
separated by the river den
so just for reference this area is the
store at battlefield as obviously the
application site
and the physical boundaries of cointen
the application is seeking outline
permission for the development of eight
dwellings
the plan before you demonstrates the
indicative layout of the site
highlighting hard dwellings can be
accommodated within the site so please
note that
this is outline permission but this does
show that is
how like it would be possible to
facilitate the eight dwellings within
the site including parking and residence
meaning space
the application site has been designated
when the carton ndp for the development
of eight dwellings
however as highlighted in the report the
application site doesn't
slightly deviate from the red line
boundary set out in the ndp
namely a small offshoot approximately
eight meters
from the southern edge boundary along
the existing track however the site is
contained with the adopted settlement
boundary
so this is the proposed application site
that's the deviation which comes along
this is the ndp site allocation plan so
you can see there is a deviation there
and this is the built up peripherals a
settlement boundary for the ndp
which does contain that offshoot and
then comes along the uppercase site
there
these are the photos of the site as you
can see that is the historic edge hill
battlefield
facing outwards this is across the road
with the dwelling setting
facing from the access point westwards
and the opposite direction eastwood's
dwellings again
and this is the fundamental site it's
very open by nature that's the nearest
property
to the west um that's the existing
hedging which comes along the northern
boundary as well as some of the eastern
boundary
and the southern boundary is very open
with the edge of battlefield once again
that's the end of the presentation as
set out in the office report the
application is considered comply with
all policy requirements as set out on
both the core strategy
and the curtin ndp and therefore also
recommendation is for planning
permission to be granted
subject to the section 106 through the
ecology offset
as set out in report there are no
updates thank you chair
joe thank you very much for that um
let's move straight to off
so we have registered for the parish uh
council
is councillor ken pritis and i'm
assuming councillor david gosling
um can you hear us please counselors you
may need to press star and six on your
phone keypad to unmute yourself if you
haven't already
counselor protest and counselor gosling
can you hear me
star and six on your keypads
just to reiterate that start and six
members just for your information i do
have a copy of the proposed
uh representations for the parish
council if we haven't been able to make
contact
in the next 30 seconds to a minute then
we will i will read that out
but i'll just see again counselor
pretties or counselor gosling are you
there
you may need to press star 6 on your
keypad to unmute your phone
just to reiterate start and six i don't
think we're going to have much success
at this
point so i propose that i will read the
representations
made by or that were proposed to be made
by canton parish council so if i may i
will do that
now so policy ssb2
of the clinton neighborhood development
plan identifies the location for
and boundaries of a development site for
eight houses
it is clear from the images contained in
the document supplied
separately that the boundary in the
application is different from that in
the ndp
we acknowledge that the confirmation of
the officers report that the development
is within albeit tied to
the settlement boundary but wish the
committee to note that the southern
boundary of the ndp site layout was
specifically drawn to give
linear continuity with the boundaries of
the neighboring properties to the west
this line will also become crucial when
any landscaping condition for the
southern boundary
is applied to a reserve matter
application
we are objecting to this application to
uphold the integrity of the ndp
in the event the committee approved this
application we recognize that this is an
outline application for up to eight
dwellings with all matters reserved
except for access
but our experience has shown that many
things can change between outline and
reserve matters approval and therefore
should this application be granted we
request that the condition
fi the proposed condition five to have
teeth
such that up to eight means precisely
that
we believe that conditions should also
be applied to protect the existing
hedgerow on the northern boundary
although this might not be uh sorry
although this might be considered
as landscaping and more relevant to
reserve mata application
our concern is to maintain a feature of
the village approach
which has developed over many decades
and not allow it
to be scrubbed out and replaced at some
later date
finally and of considerable concern
there are two conditions proposed as a
result of the wcc ecologist review
of the surveys identifying a number of
protected species
the word of those conditions refer to
applications for reserve matters
it seems based on the amount of
redaction that we are not allowed to
define one of those species
so suffice to say that that sets for
black and white fury
furry creatures exist on site and
references made to the closure of a
number of
settlements or sets sorry i do apologize
advice obtained by the parish council is
that any set
is protected unless proven that it is
not
in use sets and areas around the set
which are visited and signs of usage are
protected
even if at the time they are not
occupying the set a license cannot be
applied for until this has been acted on
and also licenses are only issued from
uh first the 7th to 30th the 11th
we ask that the greater consideration
for the protection of that species is
given in this outline
application i do hope i've given that
justice
um there we go so that is the uh
presentation from the parish and town
council
um we do have another speaker uh who is
mr george yates the
agent for the application mr yates are
you there you may need to press
star and six to unmute good evening can
you hear me
i can indeed that is a relief um mr
yates happy new year welcome
um you have three minutes we'll give you
a 30 second warning whenever you're
ready please
do begin thank you very much yeah good
evening i'm george yates
a chartered town planner at knight frank
i'm here to present to members an
outline proposal
for residential development on land
south of bambi road accountant
land south of bambi road is allocated
eight dwellings
in the accountant which was made
in 2016. the site falls entirely within
settlement boundary
for clinton as defined within both
the neighbourhood plan and the core
strategy
principle development is therefore
acceptable
the proposed access arrangement has been
subject to
rigorous assessment and the highway
authority is satisfied with the proposal
mr yates sorry to interrupt you at this
point
um yeah i'm struggling to hear you
because i think there's something
playing in the background
would do you have the live stream
running
uh yes i will leave the live stream if
you wouldn't mind that would be helpful
thank you
is that clearer now that is infinitely
clearer yes
um if you want to go back up the second
sentences that's fine um and we'll just
take a couple of seconds off the um the
clocks
for the interruption or add that to your
time whenever you're ready to continue
thank you yes thank you um so yes sorry
um
my name is george yates i'm a chartered
town planet at night frank
i'm here to present to members uh the
outline proposal for resident
development on land south of bamboo road
kinda
the land south of bambi road is
allocated for eight dwellings in
the kinds of neighbor development plan
which was made in 2016
and the site falls entirely within the
settlement boundary for chinaton
as defined within both the neighbourhood
plan and the court strategy
the proposed access arrangement has been
subject to rigorous assessment
and the highway authority is satisfied
with the proposal
the proposal will include a section of
pedestrian footwear and a pedestrian
crossing
on bambi road thus ensuring a safe and
convenient
walking route between the site and the
center of the village
secure cycle storage will be provided
and the applicant has agreed
to a condition relating to electric
vehicle charging points
the application has submitted an outline
however an illustrative
a site plan is submitted this shows how
scheme could be designed and laid out
to ensure it appears coherently around
the area
and it also shows retained and
additional planting and landscaping
around the site
which will help screen the development
and contribute towards biodiversity
the site has been assessed by the
environment agency for its club risk
there are no objections and the
application deals comprehensively
with all of its own surface water
drainage and flood rigs
mitigation including an allowance for
climate change
the update the application includes a
full suite of technical site assessments
in relation to matters such as ecology
trees
and the historic environment there have
been no formal objections raised by
officers
in relation to any of these points and
where relevant planning conditions have
been suggested
and the applicant will also enter into a
section 106 agreement
to ensure contributions towards
biodiversity offsetting are secured
following comprehensive due diligence
alongside the proactive
and collaborative work with stratfor
naval district council
all matters have now been resolved they
are very pleased to support the
recommendation of the officer
for approval of this outline planning
application and i hope that members feel
able
to support the delivery of this
allocated site thank you
mr yates thank you very much for that
members do you have any questions for mr
yates at this point please indicate in
the chat if you do
councillor parry has indicated he has a
question to cancel
[Music]
thank you chair and um good evening to
you
um i just wondered if if
we um well i appreciate this is an
outline
uh planning application and and it's um
so we'd need to come forward for reserve
matters i just would be interested to
know what your plans
are in terms of supplying broadband
direct to
what will your plans be for broadband
direct to the
properties and also bird boxes
good evening thank you um um
in terms of broadband right it surely
will be hooked up to the network
uh in in the local area i think um
whilst ultimately we we aren't going to
be the
uh end developer of this application
um clearly anyone building houses uh in
in 2021 onwards um
we'll be certainly looking to install
um you know the the best internet
connection
that's available um given given where we
are in the world right now
and uh our total reliance on on the
internet
for many parts of our life um and
in terms of in terms of back boxes i
do not recall there being any any
recommendations
uh for for those within the ecology
reports
um but but again if
if something allowed it has been picked
up and i know that there were a number
of other
recommendations in terms of ecology and
again those will be picked up
um and will be conditioned through the
outline application
lovely thank you very much i can see no
further questions from members so mr
yates thank you very much for your
contribution this evening
you're probably best served to hang up
the phone now and continue to watch on
the live stream
so thank you very much yeah cheers bye
okay we'll move to our ward member in
that case here's councillor mills
mr chairman thank you and um i i will be
very brief this evening you'll be very
pleased to know
um although this site has been
established in the
ndp i do have concerns on this
application
one being that plans show the propels
boundary to be outside that
shown on the original client
neighborhood development plan
also i have concerns over the boundary
hedge which must be retained along bambi
road to ensure
continuation of hedgerow when coming
into
and exiting the village of canton
as we know developers have the habit of
removing hedgerow to make it easier when
commencing development
but before anyone has the chance to
object
uh there have been several comments on
flood risks for this development which
do concern me
but i've noted that the environment
agency have said that they are satisfied
the development
force in flood zone one but however
on the committee report it says flood
zone two
i'm happy that this development is up
for up to eight dwellings but this
should
but should this application be granted
tonight
i would like to see a condition put on
that this development does not exceed
the eight dwellings proposed for this
site
so to summarize uh as we that's the
village of kingston
uh have had problems in the past where
developers have been rather
unclear as to where boundary lines are
on their submitted plans
i would like to see a more definitive
line on these proposed plans before any
building work is started
two a condition that the hedgerows are
maintained on
either side of the site are not just
grubbed up um
straight away when they're they start
building
uh and a condition that no more than
eight dwellings are built on the
proposed development
i would also like clarification of
whether this development is flood risk
or too um so in essence mr chairman
and committee um i object to this
application
as it stands thank you
councillor mills thank you very much
members do you have any questions for
councilman mills at this point
please indicate in the chat if you do
i don't know whether you can pick me up
from kind parish council i've come
through our conference phone now
um having missed my slot thank you
who is it i'm speaking to you sorry
david gosling from kind of parish
council
david good evening welcome i have to
tell you that frantically starring six
did not work on the
computer keypad but it does work on the
conference phone
yeah so i'm here if anybody has any
questions
um okay bear with me um you obviously
you would have heard that i've read out
your statement
let's finish off and then i'll come back
to yourself
for questions if you just bear with
please thank you so council dixon you
have a question for councilman mills do
you want to fire away
thank you chairman uh councillor mills
uh obviously you're concerned regarding
the number of eight
being the maximum if a development came
forward
which had the same square footage i.e
no more than ten thousand square feet i
think is what is in the
application indicating no more than one
000 square meters
i.e by the construction of more but
smaller properties
would you have strong objection to that
or
because i don't know what housing makes
you need that's all okay yeah
i think before councillor mills sorry to
interrupt
this that matter has been covered off by
the condition condition
five which clearly says maximum of eight
dwellings totally no more
99 sorry 999 square meters so i don't
think we need to go into that to be
honest with you
um does anyone else have any questions
for councillor mills
no okay council mills thank you very
much
thank you mr chairman thank you we will
now go to council gosling uh who
has as we've heard as is here and ready
to answer questions so members do you
have any questions for councillor
gosling
no councillor dozing thank you very much
for making the effort to
to be with us and indeed for us to be
able to hear you now
um it looks like there's no question so
feel free to continue watching um
the the live stream as we now move into
uh our deliberations
thank you chair thank you very much okay
um points of clarification to our
officer does anyone have any points they
want to raise councillor jennings is
first in
councilogenix thank you chairman so
um the parish council uh
raised this uh point about the
proposed boundaries outside of the
nation neighborhood development plan yet
it seems to be
in the ndp let's have a little bit of
clarification on that please
yeah sure it might be easier if i just
quickly share the same slide again just
so you can see
so it's easier that i can reference
everything um
can everybody see that apart from you
see your face again so far
yeah okay okay so once again this is the
application site this is
a close-up screenshot off the site with
the ndp
so there is an offshoot there that
doesn't correspond
with the red line boundary or the ndp
but the bit
settlement boundary itself does
correspond and i set out in the report
policy h1 of the ndp generally supports
development within the settlement
boundary
so that offshoot yes it's outside what
was designated there
it does correspond with policy h1 and
the settlement boundary of the ndp
um for that reason i don't think
i could it'd be a strong enough reason
to recommend refusal
obviously you could differentiate from
that but that was my reasoning i hope
that makes sense
excellent yes thank you very much
thank you uh council journalists thank
you joe we have a question from cancer
dixon for you now
please cancel dixon thank you chairman
joe
um the parish council and indeed council
mills
made some reference to the boundary
hedge to be retained
etc i appreciate there is a note
to be added to the any sanction we give
with the various conditions
knowing full well that these hedges do
get uh grubbed out
we suffered a dramatic change of one of
our rural lanes in tanworth with
exactly the similar circumstances
between an outline and a
full application subsequently is there
anything we can do
stronger than a note well if you notice
there's actually a landscaping condition
as well
so the note really is there to reinforce
the landscaping condition
we can then let's say i didn't deal with
the next application any future officer
can look at it straight away and go
that harry barringer hedging is
essential for the future development
in some ways it actually probably
reinforces the protection of the
hedgerow
because at the minute there is no
protection of that hedgerow
so it's kind of covered in the
landscaping condition
with the note as well
thank you very much which number is that
so if you go down to
[Music]
three
to apologize it's not on the report
there should have been a landscaping
condition that was put on the report for
it for the
to be decided reserved matters regarding
the boundaries of the hedging
in that case i'm going to end up
supporting it subject to that edition
fair enough thank you very much council
thank you councillor parry has a
question
thank you chad hello and good evening
joe um i wonder whether you could just
give some
clarification the parish council raised
concerns that the development
didn't reflect a linear form which
um as you can see on the
nearby development you've got a linear
form of
um to the west of the
um the site and also immediately
opposite the site um i would just
welcome your
your views on on that
and um just really
you know why why you feel it's still
acceptable to have
to have a mixed development when there
is there is a there is a strong
featuring of a bit of linear there
it would just help me to have a bit
further clarification
there's a few points regarding let me
once again go back to my slideshow
because it's easier to explain
it um so if i go back to indicative leo
firstly you've gotta remember this site
has been apart from that small edge
there has been allocated for eight
dwellings with the ndp
so the site itself has been allocated
for eight dwellings
and you're right with a linear form but
this is reserved matters application
so in the future regarding the layout
and the design
and the scale and the mass of the
development will be decided at reserve
matters application
but at the same time the ndp does
specifically state eight dwellings so
we would also have to assess to make
sure that there is sufficient parking
and space
within there and then also the impact on
the australian development
now i appreciate the linear form comes
off slightly
but you can see that it does even with
the boundary
of the ndp so which ends there
the built-up development is still within
the allocated ndp
okay thanks joe awesome lovely joe thank
you very much thank you uh councillor
parry um there is no one else indicating
they want to speak
at this point so let's move into the
debate
who uh councillor jennings is in
straightaway council james we are in
debate so far away whenever you're ready
right then obviously after looking at
all of this
it seems to be that the the hedgerow
seems to be really the only stumbling
block here and i can see no material
planning reasons to go against the
officer's recommendation
to grant this application and i'm quite
happy to
at this early stage jump in there and
say and like propose
to grant this application subject to the
extra landscaping
condition which was missing
lovely um so that's a formal proposal to
include the landscaping condition
um councillor parry i can see you
seconded that um would you like to speak
to that please
uh chair just really supporting in what
council jennings says there are no
i can't see any material planning
reasons to refuse this application
um because of its location within the
um basically within the ndp site
it's it's already identified that site
for dwellings and it is within the
settlement boundary
as long as the conditions regarding the
landscape are adhered to
um i can't see any reasons but to
support this
um so happy to second the
application the proposal thank you
lovely thank you very much um so we have
a pros and a second day before we move
into
a vote uh councillor eden has indicated
a wish to speak
counsellor edwin thank you chair i just
uh i'm not particularly comfortable with
supporting this one
unfortunately um because the
parish council have gone to the trouble
of desert thinking that area and very
clearly outlining it
i i sort of feel like the ndp should
override
the area the built to bear area if you
like
um so i'm going to struggle to support
this one because i think the ndp should
have
teeth as the parish council referred to
okay i mean that is understood um i
believe the nd
the ndp also um confirmed the bill to
perry boundary joe you may be able to
confirm that
that's correct policy h1
uh basically says that the development
in principle
is accepted within the billboard barrier
barringer given of constraints such as
landscaping harm on character and so
forth but
yes policy h1 and the settlement
boundary are adopted
okay lovely thank you very much okay
there's no one else indicated they wish
to speak
so let's move into a vote um i will
start this off
um so this this is a vote for um
granting
uh permission um at
walton farm to include a condition for
landscaping
i will start us off councillor richards
four
thank you councillor fleming cash and
flaming four
should be me
councillor eden against that's the
hunter seraphin
i agree with councillor eden against
lovely thank you very much olivia um the
committee therefore
resolves to grant um application twenty
zero one eight four zero
out uh subject to section 106 and the
inclusion of the
landscaping uh condition
good let's move to our next item
which is application reference twenty
zero zero six one five
ful that's former bowling green uh in
halford
our presenting officer is louise casey
louise are you there
i'm here thank you chairman
all right i'll just share my screen with
you now just bear with me
while you're doing that i'm going to ask
anyone uh
particularly our speakers that have
dialed in if they can press star and six
to ensure they're muted
uh but also turn off their live streams
because we are getting quite a lot of
feedback and it is delayed
um from the the actual live meeting so
there's only a few seconds but if you
could turn off your live streams that
would be great
sorry louise um over to you whenever
you're ready
hold on okay right can you see my screen
certainly can lovely okay right
so the application now four members
seeks planning permission for oh
i apologize that's the wrong side here
we go number one we'll start again
the application now former members seeks
planning permission for the construction
of four new dwellings the site is
located within the village of halford
which is a category 4 local service
village
so outlined here in red the site
comprises the form of bowling green it's
located within the halfwood conservation
area and the grade two listed half of
bridging
is situated opposite to the site to the
west so just here
so here we've got the site location on
the left and the site layout plan
proposed on the right the housing mix
would comprise one two bed property
two three bed properties and one four
bed property you can also see we've got
a new access proposed onto the foss way
just here
and here we've got the proposed
elevations of each of the plots so
top line plot one plot two plot three
and then plot four at the bottom
and now turn into some images of the
application site so top left image
number one
is taken when stood north of the site so
we can see the applications like here in
the background which is surrounded by
this
dense mature tree and hedge cover
coverage
um moving on to image number two we're a
bit close to the site this
time so here we can see the site again
this
access just here is the existing access
into the hartford bridge in
uh pub car park um image number three we
can see the halfway bridge in which is
on the other side of the road so this
image is taken we're stood in the car
park and you can see the northern
boundary of the site just here
and then image number four bottom right
um
again it's taken for the foss way um but
this time
um from south looking up towards the
side this is the western boundary of the
site just here
new access would be around about here
so now moving on to some images taken
from within the application site so
image number five looks towards the
northern boundary
image number six towards the eastern
boundary
image number seven down towards the
southern boundary and then image number
eight to the western boundaries the foss
ways just beyond this one here
okay so the current scheme is a
resubmission of a previously refused
scheme for four dwellings
that scheme was refused by the council
for three reasons
those reasons being the principle of
development
as well as harm to the character of the
streets and surroundings and also harm
to the conservation area setting of the
nearby listed building
the decision was appealed but was
dismissed by the inspector however
although it was um dismissed the
inspector disagreed with the council on
refusal reasons one and two
and found that only the works to form
the new access would cause harm to the
significance of the conservation area
so the proposal now for members has
relocated the access to the northern end
of the site
all others of the proposal remain
largely unchanged from the previously
refused scheme
so to conclude the application site is
considered to fall within the physical
confines of halford and is therefore
acceptable in principle site
specific issues regarding safety of the
new access
good design impacts on heritage assets
and also maintaining neighbors immunity
levels are all considered to be
acceptable
so chairman it's therefore recommended
that planning permission is granted are
set up within the report and there are
no
updates fabulous louise thank you very
much indeed
let's move to our first speaker who is
nicholas gale the chairman of halford
parish council councillor gail can you
hear me
you may need to press star and six to
unmute your phone
hopefully you can hear me
counselor gail are you there star and
six will unmute your keypad
just to reiterate star and six will
unmute you
could i ask our committee services
confirmed that councillor gayle is
indeed uh in the meeting
please and you know if he's in
i don't think he's managed to dial in i
have spoken to him and he will
and he was intending to dial in at the
end of the last
application but i don't think he's
managed to get in yet
okay that's fine thank you very much um
we i do have copy of
uh the presentation uh as proposed to be
presented by cancer gail so i will read
that through now
um do forgive me if i stumble over some
of the words i haven't actually read it
yet
um and it is slightly uh differently
paragraphed from how i would so please
do bear with me i hope i can do this
justice
okay so previously refused by stratford
district council this
was lodged with the planning
inspectorate in bristol and refused
again
in the opinion of the parish council
nothing has changed to suggest that this
application should not be refused
again the area was designated by
stratfor district council as
high sensitivity within holford's
historic environment
the site was home of the bowling club
dating back to 1784.
it was in active use until punch taverns
declined to enter into negotiations with
the club
for a proper lease causing it to close
until then the area was an active and
popular
recreation area for the village as a
whole
if maintained properly by the village it
would be a valuable greenfield site
within it there is no certainty that the
care recommended
in the ecological survey will be adhered
to the developers of this site are the
same as those who developed the site in
queen street
halford there it was necessary for them
to lodge a retrospective application in
order
that over 50 changes to the original
application could gain approval
this application was unwillingly
approved by the district council
the parish council have no confidence
that any protection will be policed
properly to prevent any future harm
to its surroundings to any traffic
hazards
the parish council's view is that the
entry to development is highly dangerous
at this point in the road it is where
traffic speeds are at their highest
from the traffic surveys that have been
that have taken place it is worthy of
note that some 8 000 in 12 000 vehicles
pass through the village daily
i'm assuming that means eight thousand
two twelve thousand passed through
village daily
statistics show that allowing for the 85
percentile potentially some
uh 1 500 vehicles are significantly
exceeding the speed
exceeding the speed limit the village
bus stop is positioned
so that if the entry splay were to be
put in place
this would have to be repositioned in
this case there is nowhere suitable for
this to take place
sustainability the contention that
halford is an lsv
is vitally flawed and decisions made
under this premises are very dubious
the shop is only a large kiosk there is
no school no pub and the bus service is
so
derisory as being unsuitable to convey
people to
and from work the village should be
recategorized as being one of
all other settlements in a recent
decision the district council
said regarding the proposal for halford
the character and appearance of holford
conservation area illustrates the
slow evolution over time of this
historic rural settlement
it is primarily apparent that many of
the buildings are of a simple
traditional design
with materials typical of the area this
position
this proposition is none of those
village design now the proposed
development is not one that is
community-led it is within the
conservation area it is outside the
built-up area boundary
as part of the site allocations planned
consultation have these issues
issues been fully considered the parish
council can see no pressing need to
allow this development to proceed
the district council have sufficient
sites to meet its requirements for the
force for the foreseeable future and
should therefore be refused
i hope councillors have visited the site
to understand its position and potential
problems that ends the
entire speech that would have been
otherwise presented to you by
councillor gail um obviously i can't ask
questions hopefully councillor gayle
will be able to join
shortly and i'm sure any questions you
may have can be directed to him
okay let's move then to our next speaker
who is
um councillor sarah whaley hoggins
speaking in her personal capacity and on
behalf of
residents council willie hoggins are you
there again if you press star on six to
unmute your keypad
counselor wally huggins are you there
we can i i've got a brief moment of you
speaking there
i can now good evening and welcome happy
new year to you
happy new year to all of you right you
have three minutes
with a 30 sec we'll give you a 30 second
warning if that's right but otherwise
whenever you're ready to go
please do start my family home is
immediately adjacent to the bowling
green
and as such i feel like a custodian of
it the bowling green is adjacent to the
river star and it is in this location in
halford where the remains of 11th
century castle
can still be found however in its
bowling green
are a very significant but largely
forgotten historical importance
the game of bowls has been played in the
bowling green site since 1595
and one of our church bells dates back
to 1430.
the bowling green is adjacent to a grade
2 coaching in of very considerable
proportions
which demonstrate the significance of
halford through the centuries
the bowling green has been much loved
and used throughout these centuries
magnificent and splendid trees grow
around it
there is a curious mixture of shrubs
that encircle the green and the area
with the views across the river valley
many of these shrubs and trees have been
planted as memorials to those deceased
the bowling green itself dating back to
very ancient times
is and still should be a testament and
reflection
of the ancient history of this village
and this county
the bowling green is also greatly valued
by a wide variety of animals including
birds
foxes deer and the cacophony of birdsong
which were particularly audible during
the march lockdown was incredible
this unnecessary development will rob
them of their homes too
it is an absolute travesty that we are
even contemplating the
destruction of this bit of ancient
england yet again
how can the need for a developer to
build four more houses
and make more money in a village that
has already had significant development
of similar-sized houses
in recent months outweigh the
preservation of this piece of historical
land
this was the bowling green that soldiers
returned to after two world wars
and countless civil wars william
shakespeare
himself will have been able to hear the
clink of the balls as he walks through
the village
on his way to london and the original
globe theatre
the poet chris plows provides an
adequate summary of what i am trying to
articulate
there is no path i'd rather roam than
these narrow lanes about my home
to leave my troubles far behind as i
follow its track to places kind
past verges green and crops of gold a
gentle hill along valley fold
past flower meadows over silver stream
as i lose my thoughts to nature's dream
perhaps this is the path my ancestors
walked where a lonely shepherd dreamt
where lovers talked i feel their spirits
wander by
as we journey unseen together beneath
the sky
a distant church spy at all and grand
beneath which villages prayed
for health of their land and i join with
them in a silent prayer
for the beauty around me i see i
solemnly swear
for along your path there is no wrong
just pretty flower
and bird of song nature's beauty all
around to fill my sight to fill my
sound past english oak through pastures
new
wherever you lead i shall follow you for
you
are my england you are my home and along
your country lanes
my soul shall forever roam thank you
counselor wally hoggins um it is a
refreshing change to hear
poetry during one of uh our uh
contributors and evening thank you very
much for that if you just bear with me
and i'll see if any
members have any questions for you
members do you uh counselor jennings is
straight in casa jennings
secretary um quick question about
uh the bowling green when was it when
was it last in use
um it was about four years ago when the
developers bought bought the land and as
soon as they took
possession of the land um they put a
padlock
on the gate so that access could no
longer be gained
to the bowling green there's a long
history which was
put out there it was owned by punch
taverns which is
now a dissolved company and
they decided they were they felt unable
to offer
a long term lease that to the bowling
club and just put it up for sale
um with caveats regarding the sale of if
when the if and when the land was
developed
that that they would then um get a lump
sum i can't remember the phrase that
it's called but that's what
uh land sellers often do they will get
quite
a significant uplift should there be um
development on this land but it has just
broken our hearts
to have this glorious bit of our history
padlocked from us
and um that's you know you can't play on
a bowling green
if you're padlocked and entry is barred
okay thank you thank you very much
councilman mills has a question as well
cancer mills
thanks mr chairman um sarah the um
was there any consultation with um
do you know with with the council parish
council on this
from the developer there's never been
any consultation from the developer
so right okay that's all i need to know
thank you
lovely and finally counselor parry has a
question for you as well councillor
perry
hello sarah happy new year to you
um i note in the committee report
it actually highlights during the appeal
from the inspector
that he makes reference that the bowling
green hasn't been used
since since about 2013 which is seven
years ago and also um
that there was an unsuccessful attempt
to make it an asset of
community value do you know anything at
all about that on the
application to make it up for a
community
asset i don't know much about the asset
of community value because i wasn't on
the paris council then
but i can tell you that significant and
lots of people
strained to do so but ultimately what
the um what the pub did was
the the owners they went to the highest
bid
that's how they did the bidding process
there i think the 2013
is a little bit premature i happen to
know that because uh
we moved into our house and um got
married
to the 2013 is pretty much in my mind
after we just had our anniversary
so i i can say that with the
there was bowling um subsequent to that
and also that the bowling green was was
was maintained beyond beyond 2013
as well but as soon as i said that it
passed into the
current owner's hands the padlock went
up and there was no more maintenance
of of of that and can i just say that
all it takes
is for somebody to come along and love
it once again really and to value it for
what it is
you know it just breaks one's heart to
see what has come of this land
with the sole intention that this was
just going to be
um used as um as a building
as a building site and and that
it just seems abhorrent to me so uh
i i do the frustration is there
that the opportunity hasn't been there
the the current owners haven't engaged
with
with the community at all over it
and that's what's so devastating really
thank you very much counselor ollie
hoggins um there's no one else
indicating the chat that they want to
speak so it reminds me to thank you for
your contribution particularly enjoyed
listening to the poetry as well
so thank you for your contributions and
if you want to carry on watching on the
live stream that would be great
thank you very much good evening
everybody good evening thank you
okay so we'll move now to our agent who
is wednesday wendy hopkins
uh mrs hopkins are you there can you
hear me you may need to press star and
six to unmute yourself
hello hello good evening
good evening chairman members my um my
name is wendy hopkins
i'm a chartered time planner and i'm the
agent on this application and we'll be
speaking in support
marvelous thank you very much you uh you
will be given six minutes you'll be glad
to know um as we have had
two objectives so um six minutes we'll
give you a 30 second warning whenever
you're ready do feel free to start
thank you thank you chair well firstly
on behalf of the applicant i would like
to commend
the the comprehensive assessment of the
site in this proposal given in the
offices report to this committee
the report robustly substantiates a
recommendation of your professional
advisor
in that this application should be
granted permissions subject to a number
of relatively standard conditions
if read properly the officer's report
leaves me little to add
however for the sake of completeness i
wish to take this opportunity to
reinforce the points made by the officer
on a number of the determining matters
and address some of the unsupported
claims raised in the number
in a number of the objections in regard
to the built up area boundary
the officer report acknowledges that
helford does not have an identified
built up area boundary
nor benefits from a neighborhood
development plan which might define
such an area it is also acknowledged
that the council are preparing a slight
allocation plan
which amongst other things proposes to
introduce a built-up area boundary
in local service villages however this
document is at a
relatively early plan making stage and
carries no weight in decision making
moreover given the conclusions made by
the inspector in his decision letter on
a similar scheme on this site
which is referred to in the offices
report and was referred to at the
beginning of of this presentation by the
officer
it is considered that site does fall
within the physical confines of the
village
and therefore does satisfy poor strategy
policy
cs15 as such the applicant has made
representation to the public
consultation stage of the most recent
site allocation plan
which closed on the 18th of december to
support the inclusion of this site
within the built-up area boundary
given the advice of your professional
officer in making this recommendation
i would caution against contradicting
the conclusion of the inspector on this
matter
a number of objections further received
question the status of halford as a
local service village
the report the officers report qualifies
and confirms its status as a category 4
local service village
and points to the formal prescripted
mythology
set out in the core strategy therefore
any suggestion that halford isn't
considered a sustainable settlement
able to accommodate small-scale
development
is simply unfounded the key difference
between this proposal and the previously
appealed scheme
as pointed out by the case officer is
the location
of the access as described in the
offices report the access
in the current proposal is located at
the northern end of the site
which is contained within the built form
of the settlement
where vehicle access points are a
familiar feature
as such the new access will be
experienced
as part of the settlement and visually
present
as nothing out of the ordinary and
neutral impact
on the previous scheme the point of
access was more remotely located towards
the southern part of the site
which given the amount of tree removal
required
to create the new access was considered
by the appeal inspector to materially
alter
the verdant appearance of the approach
to the village
and as such the appeal was dismissed
solely for this reason
it is the assertion of this application
that given the revised location of the
access which lies within the built-up
area of the village
minimal tree removal and the reduction
of the area of hard standing
the revised access will overcome the
inspectors concerns
which is supported by your own
professional officer
nonetheless as set out in the office's
report
the impeal inspector found that the
proposal would preserve the character
and appearance of the immediate locality
the conservation area and the setting of
the grade two listed halfway bridge inn
by virtue of the high level of natural
screening
substantial setback of the new dwellings
and their design
and appearance to deviate on this matter
would therefore be groundless
and open up the council to challenge at
appeal
the same can be said in regard to the
matter of access
the lead highway authority consider the
proposal
will provide a safe and suitable access
and as such raised
no objections to the scheme subject to a
number of relatively standard
and already agreed conditions i
appreciate a number of objections have
been received on the matter of access
which suggests
that contrary to the advice of the
professionals
the new access will be dangerous and has
poor visibility
i would therefore like to read out the
relevant part of the office's report to
provide
complete clarity the officers report
reads
despite concerns raised by the parish
council ward member
a number of third parties i give great
weight to the professional judgment of
the highways authority in these matters
so i therefore consider the proposal to
be acceptable with regards to highway
safety considerations and parking
provision
to summarize the application proposes
the efficient use of a brownfield
site contained within the physical
confines of an identified local service
village
wherein small scale development is
permissible under development plan
policy
furthermore in accordance with paradigm
paragraphs
59 68 and 78 of the mppf the
construction of four homes of varying
sizes
and not identical executive style homes
will make a positive contribution
towards the government's objectives to
significantly boost the supply of new
homes
support small and medium sites and i
quote make an important contribution to
meeting the housing requirement of the
area
your professional officer confirms that
the proposed development is acceptable
in terms of location
landscape character design appearance
heritage ecology trees access parking
safeguarding adjoining residential
immunity refuse constrainables
i'm gonna have to ask you to wrap up i'm
afraid your time has been
finished
the proposal complies with relevant
development plan policies and no other
material considerations suggest other
than members
to support the proposal and grant
permission as recommended by your
officer
thank you thank you very much we have
gone slightly over there but um
it was just to let you wrap up so thank
you we do have a question for you from
councillor parry so council power if you
want to fire away
um good evening uh wendy i just wondered
it was raised
um has been raised this evening um
that the that there's been no
engagement with the parish council could
you advise whether that's true
and if it is true can you explain why
why there has been no consultation with
the parish council regarding this
development
thank you yeah yeah thank you good good
evening councillor parry
um this this application is a revised
application
and um it's it's this is the you know
it's been going on for a considerable
period of time
and when we uh first proposed the
original application we approached the
parish council to come
to a meeting and present the application
to
you know to them but this wasn't
something that they welcomed at the time
i appreciate that there may be a
completely different
um makeup on the parish council
at the present time but um at that point
in time when we submitted the original
application
there wasn't an appetite um for us to
come and
discuss it with them um so
you know that that that was unfortunate
and obviously
this was a revised application so you
know
that um that that that's our that was
our position
okay thank you very much it doesn't
appear to be any further questions i'll
just ask members if you want to ask a
question of our agent now's the time to
do it
look at that as if by magic counselor
crump has uh has come to the party
councillor crump first time i've been
called a magician but
i'll settle for any compliment at my age
um thank you all that
mr chairman yeah i'm sorry just touching
on that last point
um yes we've had the appeal and it was a
revised uh
application i thought it'd be an ideal
time to come in and speak to
the parish council you know obviously
the previous offer was a good while ago
uh
and as we all know things have changed
dramatically over the last 12 months
for various different reasons and
probably the makeup of the
the parish council so um i've always
been taught it's good to talk and good
to make the offer so i'm a little bit
disappointed with that answer
uh and it might be for putting
applications or representing
people in in the future
you know i would appreciate the attempts
to
to speak to local people because we are
dealing with local issues
who who are the experts you know
obviously we're parish and
kennedy cat district councillors on the
planet but we're not
fully experts of that area and so um
yeah slightly disappointed about
anselmouth right so
it's i'm going to cut across you here a
little bit um whilst i don't disagree
with the sentiments of
what you've just said do you have a
question for the agent please
um well it's it is the question could
they
could they in future applications for
representing make sure they
do their best endeavors to uh
speak to the parish councils and local
people if that's possible please
yeah absolutely councillor crump yes
absolutely and
and and that is what we do on most of
our applications
um but uh if if there isn't an appetite
for that
um then you know obviously we're put in
a very difficult position
and it is only something that is
advocated it's something that isn't
mandatory
so um you know i take on board
and uh you know i'm a parish councillor
myself so i welcome
you know developers coming and speaking
to us for um
you know
you know um before applications are put
in i you know i welcome that regardless
of my own views on them
so i absolutely take on board you know
what what what you're suggesting
um you know definitely thank you
thank you
apologies my muted myself there we do
have another question from councillor
fleming for you as well so council
follow
um in your uh presentation um i heard
you describe this bowling green as a
brownfield site
how do you define it as a brownfield
site
well uh evening councillor fleming
um in the mpps and i'm just going to see
if i can grab my now
where there has been a permanent
structure on that
on on the land um and
and cartilage surrounding it then that
that would qualify as being a brownfield
site you could arguably
say that this is a brownfield site it
did have
a um as a
bowling green clubhouse on there there
has been a structure on there
unfortunately it was destroyed it was
burnt down by
um by
individuals i'm not going to i'm not
going to surmise and say
it was used but burnt it down but um
in in recent years it has been burnt
down
okay thank you it's just that
everybody's describing this beautiful
green space
and you'd describe it's a good
brownfield site but thank you for the
clarification
maybe i should have said previously
developed land
okay um i think we've got to the crux of
that one so um
no one else has indicated they want to
speak so mrs hawkins thank you very much
for your contribution this evening is
greatly appreciated
you're probably best served now to watch
the live stream uh either through the
website or or
youtube and hang up the phone but thank
you again
thank you bye-bye bye um okay so our
ward member is our next registered
speaker who is councillor
pena o'donnell casper o'donnell are you
there
i am indeed good evening chair i can see
you all
good evening and welcome you know the
drill five minutes 30 second warning
whenever you're ready feel free thank
you very much um before i start my plan
speech i just want to say i'm absolutely
astounded
regarding the reporting of the parish
council not being willing to engage
halford is a proactive and positive
parish council and i know for a fact
that there has not been an approach
since i was a councillor with halford
to discuss this matter which is
unfortunate
and also we're also putting a lot of
reliance on natural screen
with this application we have no
guarantee that few
further trees won't be removed okay so
whilst we're framing it saying
great natural shading we don't have a
guarantee that we don't i'm gonna i'm
gonna ask you to get into your the main
part i'm going into it now i'm just
about
just about to yes so committee halford
is a beautiful historic village which
has already had one new development
shoehorned into an area within the
village
which was not suitable for development
and in congress with the historic nature
of the setting
unfortunately this development was by
the applicant and resulted in a
ridiculous level of retrospective
planning applications
and concern amongst residents so you
will understand the fear
this application instills in the small
rural community of halford
committee this has now come back for a
third time and you have to ask yourself
if the applicant is hoping for success
by submission
keep returning until residents just give
in and committee members grant
ignore conservation areas and close your
eyes to build up area boundaries as part
of a site allocations plan
designated by our professional officers
and why bother looking at housing need
simply impose extra housing on a village
that neither needs nor wants it
and in doing so literally ride roughshod
over history
ignore the idiosyncrasies which make our
rural districts so special
and should be highly valued as
illustrated by resident sarah wally
hoggins with her poetry
to ignore this historic nature of both
the bowling green and half of bridging
is not in keeping with cs5
which arsenal proposals will have regard
to the local distinctiveness
and historic character of the district's
diverse landscapes
and proposals should protect landscape
character and avoid detrimental effects
on features
which make significant contribution to
the character history and setting of a
settlement or area
again i stress as did the numerous
letters of objection that this proposal
is less than sensitive to its
surrounding area
it is not in keeping with cs8 which
strives to protect the historic
environment of the district
including non-heritage assets in their
settings and that is supported by the
nppf which recognizes
that heritage assets are an
irreplaceable resource which should be
conserved in
an appropriate manner there is no
identified local need for this
development
it is not locally led and therefore not
supportive cs15
um the community response to this is
they certainly
do not feel they need it if we are
looking for land
sdc has a land bank location is not
sustainable if you are reliant fully on
a car and the bus service is
less than adequate as was indicated by
councillor gail and
is also brought up at most parish
council meetings the bowling green is a
haven for wildlife and large and
valuable trees which it is feared will
be at risk
should the development go ahead i do not
accept as i've already stated that only
the marked trees in the proposal will be
removed
given the level of shading that will
occur if the development is granted so
therefore i query
if this development is in keeping with
cs6
the location of the development is also
of concern from a highway safety aspect
as the road is incredibly busy with
traffic volume increasing and speeding
as you've heard from pc chair counselor
gail now i regularly visit halford and i
know
only too well how tricky it is to exit
the current car park
i'm also puzzled as to where the bus
stop is being relocated to
so to conclude this non-sustainable and
unwanted application is not in keeping
with halford and in congress to the very
soul of the village
it openly has little or no regard for a
highly sensitive historic environment
historical setting heritage assets local
need
biodiversity conservation areas built up
area boundaries oh and a parish council
but as we've heard they did absolutely
nothing to engage with
even after the tricky and difficult
situation they'd put both stratfor
district council and
halford parish council in with their
previous application and consistent and
ongoing retrospective planning
applications and alterations
i therefore urge a committee to refuse
and listen to locals and respect
the historical nature of halford thank
you
cancer donald thank you very much uh if
you stay on the line for a second while
we see if members have any questions for
you members if you could please indicate
in the chat
if you have any questions
10 seconds to do that
looks like you've got away scot-free
councillor donald so thank you very much
for your contribution this evening and
you're welcome to stay on and watch from
from where you are now so thank you very
much
okay let's move now to points
clarification to our officers members do
we have any questions for our
officers anything that needs clarifying
if you didn't indicate in the chat again
i'll give you a couple of seconds to do
that
counselor edin you have a question
cancer
[Music]
thank you not so much a question i just
wondered if we could put up the slide
again with the um
inspectors refusal reasons please
yep of course i'll do that for you now
lovely thank you very much councilman
mills does have a question for you
though so councilman
yes thank you um if i could ask
the officer um is this outside the uh
built up area boundary i mean i'm
confused here confused of counting
oh yeah i'll try and help clarify the
situation
so um there isn't an adopted
built-up area boundary for the village
of halford there's no neighborhood
development plan setting out a built-in
boundary the only
build superior boundary there is a draft
one within the site allocations plan but
that's not
a stage yet where we could give it
significant weight in the
decision-making process
what i would say is that the issue of
whether the development was located
within the physical confines was
assessed by the inspector an inspector
found that
he considered it is within the physical
confines and that is a significant
material consideration that we need to
take into account when making a decision
on the application
thank you lovely thank you very much and
counselor harry has the question for you
as well
counselor parry thank you thank you
chair
um it's really a technical question that
if if halford parish council
had developed a neighborhood development
plan
um would that would that have carried
some weight
if they had um specifically
put the bowling green in as a sort of
protected area
i know it's a hypothetical but it just
helps me
gain a little bit of you know
because you know because there isn't a
neighborhood development plan for
halford
and they're not part of of any other
neighborhood development plan or or
of joined forces with another
neighbouring village but presumably if
they had developed a neighborhood
development plan
could they have put that bowling green
in as a sort of
um area of restraint or or
you know that that was not to have
development i'd just like clarity on
that thank you
i think it's a very i could chip on on
that to that
david yeah speaking
in general terms counselor parry yes um
neighborhoods and communities do have
more control of development in their
area
if they produce a neighborhood
development plan and
have seen it already in this in this
very committee on the previous item
where
significant weight has full development
plan weight is given to development plan
policies within
neighborhood development plans a
neighborhood development plan in halford
could have
defined a built up area boundary or as
you say allocated areas as
uh important in respect of the uh
the contribution that they make to
conservationists
heritage character immunity um
all of those things and and so perhaps
in that respect
that is an opportunity missed um
it it perhaps also is salient to say
that um the planning system as a whole
does afford protection to
um sports fields however this uh
site falls somewhat outside of that
because it's not been in use
for five years um where a sports field
uh has been in use within five years um
a consultation would be required with
sport england um and they may object but
in this case
um that that's not been necessary as
it's not been in
active use
lovely thank you very much there's no
other questions i i did want
have one further contribution but i
didn't know whether there was any
further member questions
uh at this stage i've seen no one
indicated in the chat so please go ahead
thanks um i just wanted to make the
point that on a couple of occasions it's
been referred to
by speakers that the applicant on other
sites
in and around the area has made
proposals to vary schemes that they have
permission for
either through non-material amendment or
section 73 variation
um i think it's just important to make
the point that that's
entirely lawful for a developer to do
that as many times as they see
fit to amend their scheme to their own
satisfaction and to
to approve it um improve it sorry each
of those applications would have been
determined on on their own merit
um and i think it's probably important
there for um for members not to give any
weight
to the fact that they have taken
advantage of those
facilities available to them as it's
entirely appropriate that for them to do
so
and it's certainly much better than us
needing to take enforcement action for
example
if they had not done so a very valid
point personally i took that
as as given but um a very valid point to
me
it appears it appears my microphone was
muted externally now i had a message to
say it was
we need to have a look into why that
happened um
thank you david for your contribution
let's move into um
debate now that given there is no one
else lined up to uh to speak so
um councillor jennings will start us off
council jennings
okay thank you chairman um i might say
councillor o'donnell and councillor
whaley hoggins uh
both spoke very eloquently and i agree
with the chairman it was
nice to hear a bit of poetry but
here's the big part we're not here to
judge uh this application on sentiment
uh the bowling green is not community
owned
it's private land it hasn't been used
for over
five years therefore you don't have
things like cs25 coming into play
the principle of development was found
to be acceptable by the planning
inspector
and the previous application was refused
purely on the access um
the new application satisfies this
um therefore i see no material planning
reason to go against the officer's
recommendation
to grant this application um i would
therefore like to propose that we grant
this application
lovely thank you very much council
jennings councillor parry next please
councillor perry
thank you chair well first of all i
would like to say i can totally
understand
um you know the affinity
that halford villagers have with this
particular site
uh particularly in its with its
historical connections
um and and you know it is it has been
treasured clearly
but we have a big issue here
unfortunately
we have no objection from highways
the half of parish council don't have a
neighborhood development plan where this
site has been
identified as an area of heritage or
historical interest we
the biggest challenge we have i think if
this application was coming to us
with no no history of previous
applications in other words it hadn't
gone through an appeal process
i think our officers would be
identifying the fact
as they did in the first time around
that there was
harm being caused to the grade two
listed
um building the halford bridge
but when we have a an inspector's um
judgment um an appeal who basically says
a the site is absolutely fine
in terms of principle with the
development but more importantly
has no um identifies there's no harm
to the listed building we we just don't
have any choice whatsoever because
if we went down the route the rules of
refusal
um you know we've we've got no grounds
for planning reasons because of the
appeal
um and as i say i think it's just very
sad i think if if this application was
coming
through to us for the very first time we
would be identifying
the grade 2 listed building as causing
harm to the conservation area but we're
unable to do that
we're unable to make
detrimental comments in the access
because we've got
highways putting in no objection
and therefore um you know whilst i
totally appreciate the sentiments and
the the loss in fact of halford
villagers
we're tied i think it's it's unfortunate
they haven't got a neighborhood
development plan
so it is with regret that i will be
supporting this application
and therefore i am actually happy to
second it because i cannot see
any material planning reasons to refuse
in view of the history with the appeal
and the inspector's findings council
parent thank you very much cancer henry
sarafin next please
thank you chair i have grave
reservations of
lack of consultation with parish council
i've had many developer approach me
and i've always recommended they consult
with the parish council first
um i feel the strength of
objections should take in quite
considerable amount of weight
where you've got parish council
ward member and 33 letters of objection
um i feel this is a loss of green space
for wildlife and diversity
um i i'm
uncomfortable in gra accepting this as a
grant
thank you thank you council and seraphin
uh council dixon i see you've indicated
you wished a second do you want to speak
and don't feel obliged to given it has
already been second but if you want to
you can
i don't need to add anything to
counselor parry good man thank you very
much councillor fleming has indicated a
wish to speak
well thank you chairman um i think this
is going to be one of the worst
decisions i've ever made to support this
because the loss of these sort of
facilities in villages is horrendous but
at the same time
it hasn't been used for six or seven
years so
so i just wonder how determined the
locals were
to actually wrestle this back and and
keep it within the village
um i think all the all the various um
uh objections and whatever are very
valid i think every single one of them
valid but the point is like annan
like others um getting a planning reason
to actually say no is very difficult and
in the
in the agent speech she did say that
they would you know that we would
struggle to defend this against them
against uh if it was appealed
so from that thing like i say worst
decision i've ever made i'm gonna have
to say that
i would have to support it as well thank
you
thank you guys for flaming council mills
next please
thanks mr chairman yes what a difficult
one this is
um up all four
uh respecting um residents wishes and
he said we've got 33 lessons of
objection i i find this i mean we've all
agreed we don't like it
yeah but we've got to go by
good planning reasons um
again yeah they didn't the developers
didn't approach the uh
parish council or anybody which
obviously not planning reason i i
i'm not comfortable with this uh mr
chairman but i i will think on it but um
i'm i'm unlikely to go against it but um
anyway thank you mr chairman lovely
thank you very much councillor mills
uh we do have an occasion to speak from
our planning manager david jeffrey so
david do you want to go ahead
thank you chair just very brief comment
following um counselor hence sarah
finn's
uh comments i just wanted to uh iterate
really that the weight of objection
um is not a material planning
consideration um
and not planning reason for refusal i
think it's the content of
any comments that need to be scrutinized
not just the number
[Music]
thank you very much again a very very
valid point okay i can see no one else
indicating their wish to speak in the
chat we have had a proposal and a
seconder the proposal is to grant in
line with the officer's recommendation
and indeed that has been seconded um so
far as i can see there are
no i'm just double checking there are no
updates so we can move to
a vote on the basis i will go first on
the basis that i can see no material
planning reasons to
go against the officer's recommendation
i will vote for
german councillor fleming after serious
thought i'm going to abstain
thank you
councillor kendall
councillor chrome pub stein dixon
caps for the dixon for
olivia your microphone is very very
quiet at the moment i'm struggling to
hear you i don't know if you can get
closer to it um counselor ed unx on the
list
yeah council red and abstain i think
okay councillor hunter seraphin council
and
servant of stone councillor jennings
councillor jennings four councillor
mills
council mills against and councillor
parry
councillor parry regrettably four yeah
that's a five
four one against and four abstentions
[Music]
sorry uh olivia did you say five four
and one against
yeah five four one against four
abstentions
lovely thank you very much therefore
community resolves to grant application
twenty zero zero six one five
f u l uh in line with officers
recommendation
uh okay let's move to our next item now
remember it is half past seven
um i just remind you we have an hour uh
before we have to start the last item
so if we could i don't want to stifle
debate and discussion but if we could
keep our points and questions concise
that would be very very helpful
um councillor kendall has indicated that
he's having issues with his broadband so
has removed his camera facility just so
everyone
uh knows that um we will still be able
to hear from him he is still here but
you can't see him
okay um our next item then uh let's say
twenty zero one six
five four rem that's london north of
morton morrow lane in
lighthorn um our potential officer is
aaron
williston i can see aaron has got
herself ready to go
so aaron whenever you're ready please do
start
thank you can you see the screen okay is
the presentation loaded
uh we certainly can before you do start
i'm just going to say
for speakers that have registered to
speak um i can hear feedback from the
live
stream um your best serve to turn off
your live streams and follow along
on your handsets there is a slight delay
um and the handset will be live so if
you could follow on your
your handsets please and if you could
also make sure you are muted
that will be helpful um erin i apologize
whenever you're ready we can see your
screen so whenever you're ready please
do start
thank you chairman the application site
lies to the west of blight hall
sentiment which is identified as a
category 4 local service village within
the council's adopted core strategy
the site comprises of a parcel of land
located to the north of moreton maryland
outlined here in red on the plan the
conservation area is outlined in pink
and lies to the north and eastern
boundaries you can see just here
public right of way sm f68e lies to the
west of the site
approximately here in a slightly
different location to the dashed line
shown on the plan
outline planning permission has been
granted four free dwellings on the site
with all matters reserved except for
access
this proposal forms a reserve matters
application for the three dwellings with
details submitted for the proposed
layout
scale appearance and landscaping of the
development
this slide shows an aerial image of the
area the site lies approximately here
with open land to the west you can see
here to the south
and neighboring properties pair of
properties just here to the east
and along the southern edge of more
tomorrow lane
just here the land slopes down from the
north
to the road and it's approximately five
meters changing ground level
at its deepest point as part of the
development a landscape buffer is
proposed to be retained to the west of
the site
in approximately this location with the
new dwellings closest to the existing
properties are along to the north of
more tomorrowland
this lighter proposed site plans for the
development the plan to the left of the
site shows the entire site
with the landscape buffer hatched just
here
the public right of way follows
approximately here
to the right of the slide is a proposed
site layout for the three dwellings
they would be spaced across the site and
set approximately 12 metres back from
the road
new planting is proposed along the front
and boundary of the site
and in the landscape buffer each
dwelling will be served by a carport
located to the east of plot 1 plus 2 and
to the front
of plot 3. the development would require
engineering work to facilitate the works
and a new a level condition was applied
at outline stage to ensure a
satisfactory appearance
this slide shows the proposed elevations
for the new dwellings
new dwellings will be two story in
height and have features such as pitch
roof
dormer windows gable features to the
rear
and a combination of materials including
render
thatch stone and slate
this slide shows proposed floor plans
for the development at ground floor
level living accommodation is provided
and at first full level each dwelling
would have four bedrooms
each dwelling would be served by a
carport which is shown to the east to
the right of this slide
got plot one with a double carport and
plots two and three with a single
carport shown just here
this slide shows a number of photographs
that were taken
looking towards the site
this photograph was taken looking from
the road to the western edge of the site
looking at the top right image it was
taken from watermore lane
looking towards the site which is just
here on the left
the bottom left image was taken from
close to the access of the public right
of way which follows in this location
here
this is the application site to the
right and the final photograph was taken
from the public right-of-way
looking east into the application site
and you can see the neighbouring
property
just here on the photograph
these photographs were taken from within
the site the first was taken looking
eastward so we can see the neighboring
property
and then the top right was panning
around to the north of the site you can
see neighboring properties at the higher
level
the bottom left was taken looking
towards the west northwest of the site
see the existing vegetation and the
final photograph was taken looking west
towards the public right of way
and to the left of the image you can see
the vegetation that fronts the road
this slide shows additional photographs
taken from the road the top left image
was taken looking east along the road
and the site is visible to the left of
the image so looking into the village
here
and see neighboring properties just here
to the right of the image
this photograph in the top right was
taking looking closer to the settlement
you can see neighboring properties just
here
and the site to the left the bottom left
image was taken looking
along the road with the closest
neighbouring properties shown here to
the right of the image
with the application site approximately
here and the final photograph is looking
along multimoral lane with the
application site on the right hand side
this slide shows a number of dwellings
which lie within close proximity to the
app to the application
site just to give a feel for different
design features and materials within the
wider area
there are a number of updates for this
application which have been circulated
on the update sheet
it is recommended that planning
permission be granted subject to the
conditions and notes outlined within the
officer report and on the update sheet
thank you aaron thank you very much for
that uh we'll move straight to our first
speaker who is councillor mike langhorne
from my
home parish council councillor langhorne
are you there can you hear me
can you hear me i certainly can it's
such a relief when we
hit people on the phone um okay i think
you know the drill um
it's three minutes uh that you have to
speak we'll give you a 30 second warning
you can stay on for questions afterwards
that'd be great whenever you're ready
please do feel free to start
uh thank you chair good evening
everybody and yes i'm the
councillor mike langhorn vice chair of
lighthorn parish council
that is objecting to this application
and the reasons for our objection are
set out in the offices report
what i would like to bring to the
committee's attention for this evening's
consideration is
the development of this site um has been
sensitive in the past
uh it took three goes to get the outline
planning consent
the first two having been withdrawn or
rejected and
i would note that the last outline
planning application
was in fact recommended for refusal by
planning officers but was over
turned and agreed by this committee
that specifically noted several things
it's very much pointed out that there
was support
from lighthorn parish council for
development as helplines
from the ward councillor mills and that
there was no
local written objections
the details set out in the outlying
planning application
particularly relating to scale citing
build finish
were all noted as contributing to
a desire to support the online planning
application
and the committee asked for a note to be
placed on the
documentation to that effect emphasis
was made to seeing a sympathetic
development
with some reference made to smaller more
affordable properties for younger
families speaking and the webcast of the
event which was in march 2018
i'd no particular remarks by the chair
council barnsfield and
harry um consistent with the points i've
just brought your attention
um the committee received um an agent
obviously this was for a previous
landowner who sold the land to the
developer now making application
where they noted that the properties
would be one and a half stories finished
in local limestone
to be sympathetic to the village setting
the application before you conflicts
with
all these points or a number of these
points that were
considered by the planning committee in
giving approval outline which i would
underline as
there is now no local support for the
application and i'd point out that the
developer has not consulted
the paris council the design shows
buildings a tad larger than those
indicated by outline
but only one of the properties is being
proposed to be finished in local
limestone
and the design is for three four bedroom
properties
um which in our opinion are unlikely to
qualify as being small and scale
affordable for younger families
um these are points i would invite the
committee to take into account
along with the planning reasons for
objecting
as you deliberate thank you indeed
thank you very much uh councillor
langhorne uh will just go with us while
i
see if any members have questions for
you members could you indicate the chat
if you would like to ask
council and hallmark question council
jennings is first up chester jennings
thank you chairman thank you councillor
um just quick one
how many houses in the village um are
in local limestone
as a percentage so i i cannot give you a
definite percentage um the village has
been developed
over a number of years and many of the
developments in the 70s and
80s were not in local lunchtime but
there's been development
in the 90s that is in local limestone
and then
one of the more recent new developments
at home
farm has been finished in stone
i cannot say whether it's limestone but
it's finished there all the properties
are finished
so as to be sympathetic with the village
vernacular or the dominant
there's quite a variety within the
village
there is a variety in the village that
is true okay
thank you very much lovely thank you
very much both of you
um i can see no one else indicating
anything in the chat and their desire to
speak
so um mr castle einhorn thank you very
much for your contribution this evening
once again you'll be better off watching
from the live stream now
rather than over your phone so you can
hang your hand set up but thank you
again
thank you okay let's move to our next
speaker um
i have on my register uh a miss
amanda stobbs is that correct mr obs are
you there
i'm hoping you are i can hear someone
coughing so i'm assuming we also have on
the line
um andy sorry dude i'm going to
pronounce this wrong duden
i think that's right thank you ah amanda
hello
good evening welcome
i've recited two names andy and mark i'm
presuming that uh they're on the line as
well to answer questions
is that correct that's correct yeah
that's correct yes marvellous okay so um
in that case amanda you have three
minutes we'll give you a 30 second
warning whenever you're ready do feel
free to start
great thank you chairman and councillors
uh i'm speaking on behalf of the
applicants
grave profits limited who are a
privately owned residential development
company based in stratford-on-avon
they have a proven track record of
delivering quality homes employing local
trades and services throughout
warwickshire and the west midlands
grave acquired the site at linehorn with
the benefit of outline planning
permission
the outline permission reserved matters
relating to layout scale appearance and
landscaping
and subject they are the subject of this
proposal
matters relating to access were agreed
at the outline stage albeit subject to a
later approved variation
and therefore determined to be
acceptable the outline commission
approved three market housing
dwellings this is confirmed in the
offices report we emphasize in response
to comments made by the parish council
there is no requirement for the decision
notice any planning agreement
or within the council's adopted policy
for this scheme to provide affordable
housing
the decision notice required as an
informative that the scheme be
broadly in accordance with the
illustrative plans outlined on drawing
pa-02
and that is an indicative street scene
grivain has developed the scheme in
consultation with the case officer and
responded to the comments made
particularly with regards scale and
layout it is highlighted that the case
office considers the scale to be
proportionate to the size of the site
and would not harm the character of the
area
and that the layout is also considered
to be sympathetic to the character of
the area
accordingly it is determined the
proposal is in accord with the outline
scheme
and as confirmed by the case officer
acceptable and in accord for the
council's policy
pride themselves on delivering quality
housing that is varied and interesting
the style of building and material
proposed was selected with reference to
buildings within the village and
specifically within the adjacent
conservation area and light on
conservation area review
the review states that it is essential
that more effort is made to ensure that
and i quote
new development respects the traditional
forms and materials if the quality of
the village is not to be eroded further
as identified by the case officer the
materials are generally encored with the
council's spd as traditional materials
and are sympathetic to the character of
the area and are thereby appropriate
in addition to the above it is noted
there was no adverse effects in respect
of
residential amenity the water
environment or flood risk
historic or natural environment in
summary
the proposals are in accord with the
approved outline scheme and
confirmed by the case officer conform to
the council's adopted development plan
and associated guidance
and the requirements of the mppf such
that the reserve matters approval should
be granted and we support this
conclusion
thank you for listening thank you very
much well within your three minutes
members do we have any questions
for our agent uh the applicant or their
architect
please indicate in the chat if you do
i see no action so it looks like that's
a no um amanda thank you very much
uh and mark if you're on the line thank
you as well for joining us this evening
um your contributions are very valuable
you're best served again watching online
now and hanging up your uh your handsets
but thank you again
thank you cheers okay we will move now
to our final speaker for this item which
is councilman mills cancer mills you
know the drill five minutes thirty
second warning
do start thank you mr chairman again i
will be very very brief i promise
um once again good evening committee um
i originally supported this application
on the understanding
uh it was for affordable housing which
is much needed in lighthorn
um lighthorn has had several new build
developments in the past few years
and the prices vary from you know four
six hundred thousand to a million
and therefore the village of light or
needs more affordable housing to enable
young families
who prefer village life to establish
establish themselves in light hall
unfortunately the four bedroom homes
shown on the plan submitted
under reserve matters do not match this
criteria
large larger four bedroom two-story
homes are not what the village of
lighthorn needs
far from it this development was
originally to be modest
not four bedroom homes they are
inconsistent as the new plan showed
dwellings to be much larger than the
original plans
the proposed development was described
as to suit the immediate street scene
which it certainly does not in fact
in adjacent properties are more modest
semi-touch
properties or cottages therefore the new
proposed development does not suit the
immediate surroundings along
more moral lane also the original
materials
were described as limestone but not but
only one is now finishing limestone
so to summarize i can't emphasize enough
the new plans show
two-story four beds which are contrary
to the original plans of three beds
of one and a half stories and also the
wishes of the residents
in light hall the four bedroom homes are
not what the village of lighthorn needs
the new proposed application is totally
out of character with the street scene
along morton
lane and to re-emphasize my comments as
on the committee report
we were led to believe that all the
proposed new homes were to be built in
lions stone
but now we only told that only one
property is finishing limestone which i
can only take
as a token gesture by the developer
i will obviously leave it to the
committee to make the decision much in
my opinion
this application as it stands must not
allow it to be granted thank you very
much mr chairman and thank you committee
thank you very much councillor mills you
have a question from councillor parry
i thought i would
um can you advise when
the parish last carried out a housing
needs survey that identified specific
housing i can't i can't
[Music]
but um perhaps the officers might be
able to confirm that no probs
so sorry anne okay
um i could see no one else indicating
their desire to ask you a question
councilman
so it looks like you've got off
scot-free we will move then
we will move then to um uh any points of
clarification to our offices would
anyone like to ask our officers a
question i'm assuming councillor parry
might
counselor jennings is first up though so
council jennings fire away
very generous of you very gentlemanly
counselor parry
thank you um erin i wonder whether you
can advise the
status on housing needs survey for
lighthorn parish council and
also i also wanted to ask that if we
were minded
to grant would would we be able to
insist
on um all three properties
being built of limestone
material thank you
thank you in terms of housing needs
survey i understand there was one
carried out
in um 2013 for
lighthorn parish council and in this
case what we're considering is three
open market dwellings and that was what
was considered an outline stage
and so we're looking at these as open
market dwellings on the site
in terms of the finish of the
development we have to consider what's
been submitted so there is a condition
that's recommended that we have samples
of the materials that are proposed
um by officers and that the combination
materials is what we're considering at
this stage so it is the mix of
the the render and the thatch and the
limestone and the brick in in this case
that's what
that's what's been put forward by the
applicant
okay thank you very much council
jennings do you want to come back yes i
was wondering whether erin might be able
to bring up the photo
of the property which was opposite the
entrance or the proposed entrance
can you see my screen okay i can see it
yes
so if i just go down through the
photographs
so this is the closest neighboring
property just here on the right
and as you're looking away from the site
you've got other neighboring properties
just here you can see just the right of
the image
right so the picture on the bottom left
is the
semi detached that's correct the pair of
semi-detached properties which are
located just here on the plan if you can
see in the bottom left of the slide
so the application site is approximately
here and it's the pair of properties
here
looking back towards the site in this
location looking west
from the road okay so i was just a bit
confused about cottages they don't look
very much like cottages to me okay thank
you very much
okay i can see no one else indicating a
desire to uh
clarify any points with our officer
aaron so
let's move to the debate who is going to
kick us off
councillor jennings is good man council
jennings
thank you chairman well first of all
designs
very subjective matter i mean out of
these three
one of them being um of this of
limestone
is probably reflective of the village of
all the different types so i really
don't have a problem with the design on
it
the size seems to be acceptable to the
officer
um and again
for me to go against the officer's
judgment on this i'd have to give some
very good planning reasons
and i can see absolutely no material
planning reasons to go against
the office officer's recommendation uh
to grant this application so therefore
i'd like to propose that you grant this
application
lovely thank you very much and do we
have anyone else our counselor kendall
has indicated a desire to second council
kendall do you want to speak to your
second indian
yes thank you chair very briefly i i
don't want to go over it again um
council jennings has said it all for me
i can't find any reason to go against it
so i'm happy to second top stuff
thank you very much uh no one else has
indicated their desire to speak so we'll
go straight to a vote the
proposal that has been seconded is the
grant in line with the officer's
recommendation i will go first
councillor richards iv thank you
fleming castle
kendall councillor kendall four
jennings for councillor parade
councillor paris iv that's unanimous
chair
fabulous thank you very much olivia so
uh committee therefore resulted grant
application twenty zero one six
five four rem uh land author of morton
lane in lighthorn uh in line with his
officer's
recommendation let's go straight to our
next application we have erin
uh presenting to us once again this is
application twenty zero
two four three ful land adjacent to
romney's rest um
in edge hill aaron once again before you
start you know uh
for those speakers that have just joined
us if you could please follow along on
your handsets
and turn off any live streams we do get
a lot of feedback
uh so it makes it a little bit difficult
um and i'm gonna
mute um i'm gonna mute everyone just in
a sec
because i'm getting a lot of feedback
now aaron you will need to unmute
yourself
before you start but
do feel free to begin whenever you're
ready
thank you please check everyone can see
the slides presentation on screen
certainly can the application site lie
to the southwest of edge hill settlement
which is identified as an all other
settlement within the council's adopted
core strategy
the site lies within the cotswolds area
of outstanding natural beauty
and close to a potential wildlife site
the site also lies within 500 metres of
ancient woodland
which is shown here in green on the plan
the site lies to the south of broadway
conservation area and grade 2 star
registered park and garden which is
outlined in pink on the plan
but sets approximately 100 metres away
from the site
public footpath sm-170d lies to the west
of the site
as shown here by the green dash line
the application site is outlined in red
and includes an existing vehicular
access
and parcel of paddock land shown just
here planning permission is sought for
the erection of a single
self-filled local market dwelling and
associated works
this slide shows an aerial image of the
area with the approximate location of
the site
outlined in red just here with the
access up to the highway
the land to the north and to the south
of the site
paddock land the existing menage an
equestrian building
you see just here to the southwest of
the site edge hill quarry
the land to the rear of the site is used
for the storage of vehicles
and equestrian agricultural buildings
and up to the north allotments are shown
just here
and the neighboring properties include
grove and located here
and romani rest to the north east of the
site
[Music]
this slide shows a proposed site plan
for the new dwelling located just here
on the slide the dwelling would be set
back approximately 55 meters from the
road you can see just here
and certify the existing vehicular
access which is gated to the road
approximately here new parking and
turning areas
are shown to the front of the property
and a new private garden area
is proposed to the rear
this slideshow to propose floor plans
and elevations of the new dwelling
dwelling would be two-story in height
with three bedrooms of accommodation at
first floor
an attached carport shown just here to
the side of the property
the dwelling will be finished in natural
stone under a towel roof and the design
features include
a canopy feature to the front pitch roof
door windows and chimney
solar panels are proposed on the south
east facing roof slope
just here and a new air source heat pump
is proposed to the side of the property
just here on the drawings
this slide shows the number of
photographs taken from the road
the top left image was taken looking
towards the site along the existing
access
the approximate location of the new
dwelling would be where the arrow is
just here as the access
bends around to the left as you drive in
the top right image was taken looking
towards
edge hill and the access is just there
just heading in this direction
the bottom left was taken looking in the
other direction south west along the
road from the access
the final image was taken looking back
towards edge hill
from a southeast location away from the
application site so the site's
approximately here the access and just
looking back towards the settlement
this slide shows a number of photographs
which were taken from within the
application site
the top left image was taken from the
access road looking in a southeastern
location
this is the approximate location of the
new dwelling you see the existing
vegetation to the rear
and buildings as well to the southeast
of the site
the top right image was taken looking
across towards romani's rest and the
existing paddock land is visible at the
forefront of the image
bottom left image was taken looking back
towards the road which lies
approximately here behind the hedgerow
and you can see the building over here
visible as you're panning around the
site
and the final image was taken looking
back towards the road and see the access
point here
looking south with a neighbouring
boundary treatment just here
there are no updates for the application
and it is recommended that planning
permission be refused for the reasons
outlined
within the officer report thank you
erin thank you very much for that we
will move straight to our first speaker
uh who is the chair of radley and upton
parish council adrian
berry councillor adrian berry um
counselor are you there can you hear me
you may need to press star on six to one
can you hear me okay certainly can again
relief to hear you
um you may have worked out by now that
you'll get three minutes we'll give you
a
30-second warning otherwise whenever
you're ready please do start
okay a concern regularly raised by
rutley and upton parishioners is the
lack of suitable housing for local
children to live in
once they move out of their family home
the policy of no new housing means that
small houses have been extended and
terrace is not clear into single houses
the result is that the children have to
move away losing their family ties and
hollowing out community
there are now hardly any young children
left the school is gone
and the 40 year old youth club is now
struggling for members
similarly long-term residents who wish
to downsize also cannot stay in the
community
over the years rutland parish rutlin
upton parish council has conducted three
housing needs surveys
all have demonstrated a requirement for
additional housing to enable people to
stay in the community
this application meets one of those
identified needs for a younger person
who works in the parish and wants to
stay here in their own family home
therefore the parish council actively
support this application the planning
office report is well researched
and documented however the
recommendation for refusal
hinges on the subjective assessment that
the proposed site is in
open countryside and hence conflict in
the policies
10 part a and cs 15 part g
rattling upton parish council disagree
the report claims that there are no
close neighbouring dwellings yet
identifies both grove end
on the opposite side of edge of lane to
the west and romney's rest to the
northeast as being only 100
and 130 meters away the report does not
identify
that to the west of grovin there is an
existing industrial site
that houses a haulage company ac
services
there is a large lawyer yard several
existing out buildings and a new
two-story office block under
construction
the applicant works at this industrial
site which is a short 160 meter walk
from the proposed new house
so there is no need to drive to work on
the north side of edgehole lane
about 115 meters from the parasite are
the local allotments with a myriad of
huts
the report notes that to the south side
of the site lies eduard quarry
in fact the quarry starts at the north
east and wraps all the way around the
south and southwest sides
all the way to eduard lane in the west
apart from the adjacent agricultural
buildings at romney's rest
175 meters away on the east side of the
quarry stands at barn complex
260 meters where on the south side is
white bottom's farm house
and the large commercial riding service
is created in 30 meters away
the parish council's opinion is that the
proposed site is already surrounded by
either industrial commercial or existing
housing sites
it is not in open countryside a
reasonable edge hill village boundary
would run from grove end on mitchell
lane
and around the boundary between the
quarry and the proposed site
i.e in our opinion the site meets the
requirements of both as10 part a
and qf-16 part g thank you
thank you very much there councillor
barry um
members do you have any questions for
our counselor council
please
i've seen very little action here uh
council barry looks like you've uh
you've nailed it there you've no
questions available for you so thank you
very much
uh for your contribution this evening
again if you you're best served watching
the
sorry live stream sorry i i i lost your
question
sorry sorry counselor jenny that came in
uh before i started speaking so
castle jennings does have a question for
you council barry council james willis
yeah so thank you councillor um just a
quick a very quick one
this haulage yard whereabouts is it
again
it's to the west of um of
of uh drove end so the other side
virtual lane
you can actually see it on the slide
that's presented the aerial view
if we could have the aerial view again
that would be helpful we do have that
aerial view in front of us now
is that okay yeah is that ac services
that's the one that's pretty good thank
you very much
yeah there was a planning application in
last year for the new office block
that's going up there okay lovely um
this time uh it looks like there are no
no further questions for our members so
thank you again uh councillor barry for
your contribution if you want to
continue to watch on the live stream
you'll be better off doing that you can
hang out
thank you very much bye cheers okay
let's move to
our agent who is mr ruben bellamy
uh mr bellamy are you there can you hear
me you may need to press star and six to
unmute yours
i can indeed thank you very much for
being here
um so i think you've gotten done what's
happening now you've got three minutes
you'll have 30 seconds and if you can
stay on for any questions afterwards
that would be great whenever you're
ready do start
okay thank you good evening ladies and
gentlemen um yes my name is reuben
bellamy
acting on behalf of daisy hughes daisy
the applicant was born
and has lived in the parish all of her
life which is for 25 years
and previous generations of the family
have lived there for at least 150
and she's worked in the villages leaving
school the difficulties faced by
young people in rural areas and the
consequent impact and the vitality of
rural communities are well known
and expertly expressed by the parish
council just now
access to housing lies at the heart of
this problem stratfor district has
long-standing policies designed to
address this
initially through the local choice and
now through the local housing needs
policies in the core strategy and the
spd
but today no local needs dwellings have
been constructed in the village
this proposal has to support the local
community from the parish the ward
member
and 14 letters of support it responds to
an identified need in a recently
conducted housing needs survey
daisy clearly meets the local connection
criteria and it is a small scale
proposed refusal hinges on whether the
site is within or adjacent to the
village
the previous application proposed a
dwelling only 60 metres closer to the
heart of the village
which was considered acceptable except
for an objection
from environmental health due to a
nearby stable so the dwelling has been
moved away from the stable
to a site that allows for an existing
access to be used
with no loss of existing hedgerow
edgefield does not have a built-up area
boundary and so we are into matters of
judgment
and i noted what the officer said at the
halford case earlier
about the weight to be given to the buab
um that also applies to the methodology
that hasn't been tested the village edge
is characterized by sporadic built form
which is fairly typical and opposite the
site is a dwelling in a recently
constructed office building as you've
just heard
it joins a quarry at the rear of the
site are agricultural machinery storage
buildings
the dwelling would fit perfectly within
this character and cannot describe as
remote
it would appear and be considered as
part of the village and therefore will
comply with policies cs15
and as10 it's also a self-build and if
approved it will count towards your
self-built supply duty
an important material consideration this
is an attractive traditional style
building
which will be built in hortonstone from
the adjoining quarry
and it will have high environmental
performance as it incorporates
photovoltaics
air and ground source heat pumps and an
ev charging point
the reliance on the car will be no
different if it was cited in a
previously acceptable location
and in any event we've got an ev
charging point proposed
to conclude this application has
community support
a fact to which the sdp states that
significant weight will be given by this
council
it is an excellent proposal for
self-built dwelling that sits four
squared your local needs policies
for a local person it meets your high
climate emergency requirements
and it comply with the development plan
and on this basis we respect the request
that you approve this application thank
you very much for listening
mr bellamy thank you very much for your
contribution um members do we have any
questions for our agent
please indicate in the chat
if you do i'm going to give an extra 10
seconds
seconds this time for cancer jennings to
finish typing
just in case he gets me at the end
looks like that's a no so uh mr bellamy
thank you very much for your
contribution
um if you want to continue to watch on
the live stream you'll be best placed to
do that
um and you can hang up your uh your
phone when you're ready so thank you
once again
thank you very much thank you cheers
okay
our final speaker for this item is
councillor fielding who uh i believe
is within our meeting chat so cancer
fielding if you'd like to turn on your
microphone and your camera so we can see
you
and you will have five minutes
okay i can certainly hear you uh so
you'll have you've got five minutes uh
we'll give you a 30 second warning
whenever you're ready to
please feel free to start thank you very
much
um erin can you point out the stable
block
and also the other side of the road
where the
offices are being dealt with thank you
um just to keep um
councilor mills happy this has gone
through the parish council
um they've had lengthy conversations
with the family uh about this
development
the reason i asked for the stable block
was the fact that
they put in an application to be near
the stable block because
the daisy um hughes
does ride and they do bring horses over
for sale from ireland to this country
and sell them on so
to an extent it was going to be helping
to look after the horses
but because of the problems with um
building two being too close to stable
block
it went to appeal and the appeal turned
down that particular point
but it lost on appeal because of
there were there had not been a housing
needs survey
this housing needs survey has now been
carried out
and can you keep the plan up please
sorry
it's gone um because of that
she has now asked to put an application
in on that road you can see going to
where her father stores and keeps
um his vehicles part of it
is there because of the horses part of
it is
she wants her own property on her
parents land
and partly because she's got to look
after the horses
on the opposite side of the road as
discussed and as pointed out
there is an office block plus a um
probably an ex-quarry but it is now
a storage for commercial vehicles which
is right on top
of the woodland that and the footpath
that was shown in the previous by the
planning officer
the quarry is subject to
a planning application for refilled with
county council it was or they were also
looking to put some affordable homes in
but i managed to persuade them to wait
until they'd got
the the land refilled before they
started to
come forward with those sort of plans
but it
very much proves in my view that it is
not
open countryside the
one of the um concepts which the
owners of the quarry as it is refilled
is not only is it
going to be a nature reserve in part but
also it's going to have uh camping this
um glad camping setups for people to
come and stay
and cycle around the district to
enjoy our beautiful countryside
the village has a pub the castle which
although it's
actually not in edge hill it's actually
in radway
but it's very much a popular watering
hole
for a number of people coming from and
in the past it used to be a part of the
tea rooms were all up there
people coming up from london and
elsewhere by
sharabang to look across the views so
there has been a lot of activity in the
village
which sadly because of modern transport
and things
has rather died away but i very much
want you to approve this scheme because
it is within
the village compound created
by the quarry the fact that
permissions being given on the other
side of the road for
um at lorry park and also offices
and also there are some very valuable
vehicles parked there
and some valuable horses and so by
allowing her
to have accommodation there it will um
make life a lot easier for the family
and also for
her running her own business i
rest my case
thank you councillor feeling for that uh
members do we have any question cancer
dixon straight in casa dixon far away
thank you chairman councillor fielding
you mentioned lamping on the
uh old quarry site et cetera uh has
a that been given planning permission or
is that something which is
in only in prospect and the second and
secondly
the officers across the road were they a
replacement of something that was
already there or was it as continue
a new development on an open site i
would have to get
um comment from the chairman i can't
remember when they
gave them planning permission but it's
very recently
the quarry at the present moment is
going before
warwickshire county council for
refilling and
therefore i don't think it has yet been
approved
um but i do know that this year there's
been a lot of work
done and i actually got sdc's planning
officers
and warwickshire county council um
representative and also the owners to
try and sort out
one of these cash 22 when no one can
make their mind up as to what was going
to happen there
okay i'm afraid i'm not going to be able
to answer the question as says cancer
dixon put either uh cancer feeling i'm
afraid
um does anyone else have a question for
for our board member
please indicate in the chat if you do
nope okay council building thank you
very much uh for your contribution
um do feel free to to carry on watching
from um
from where you are now okay let's move
to um points of clarification for our
officer do we have any points to be
clarified by aaron
please indicate in the chat if you do
counselor jennings
thank you chairman uh thank you aaron um
just to sort of
get my head head around this properly um
this uh the the boundary lines
it seems to be a bit blurred here um
what do you regard as the the village
boundary
and how do how do we assess that
so in terms of the assessment that we've
carried out is we're looking at whether
or not for a local market scheme it
needs to be adjacent to the physical
confines of the settlement
where there's no built up area boundary
or village boundary which is the case in
this instance
it's a matter of planning judgment we do
have some guidance set out
um in the annex to the emerging sbd
documents
which is helpful to give an indication
of what's normally included in the
physical confines or a built-up area
boundary
so that's what officers have used as
part of the assessment in this case
there was also an earlier application
and that was considered at appeal and in
the officer report
um it was considered that that site was
to the south western edge of the
settlement
and so that's something that we've used
in our assessment as well and the reason
that failed at appeal is that there
wasn't the evidence to support a local
market scheme at the time
since that time we've now got an
up-to-date housing needs survey
for for the parish um so those are the
key considerations
we take into account things like the
land use um
what built form is surrounding the the
site as well and so the officer
report goes through those material
considerations and in our view it's
considered that the site doesn't fall
within the physical confines or adjacent
to the physical confines of edge hill
in this case lovely thank you very much
councilman mills next please
thanks mr chairman erin um can you put
the
you put some photo house up earlier can
you put them up again you know
i think it was four in a block um
yes i'll just find those now okay thanks
can you see that okay yeah uh it wasn't
that wasn't that one
yeah that's the one um top left as i
look at it there's um
what is that that building there what is
that
so these are the buildings located just
here uh which equestrian agricultural
buildings
and there's existing screening and then
the storage of vehicles is
just approximately here so the access
follows down
and that's where you join this area here
in the bottom left plan if you can stop
it
so erin uh just my say that the
the proposed development it is in front
of this
this that area there where you are there
yes this is approximate site just here
so it's backing on to that okay that's
one thank you very much
thank you marvelous and finally
councillor dixon please
thank you chairman erin um are you able
to uh
advise when the office block on the
other side was given permission was it
actually a replacement or was it
you know a new land new build
and we had an application it was 2020 so
last year
um for a new two-story office block um
across
near grove end and we did have an
earlier lawful development certificate
back in 2006
and that related to the storage of
polish vehicles on the site
and so it was a new office block i
understand it was replacing existing
pre-fabricated buildings from the
description
thank you okay i can
see no further comments or requirements
for clarification in the meeting chat so
let's move to debate
who would like to kick us off
don't jump at once council jennings the
ever reliable
uh cass jennings over to you yep and
to me this is this is one of the reasons
why they do that these housing needs
surveys
and i'm all in favor of self builds
um and i think they should be encouraged
but as always here comes the big butt um
it seems to be this struggle about
whether it's part of the village or not
um the haulage yard across the road
again each planning application is
judged on its own merit
and so yes there has been a building
there but we don't know that
we don't know the background to it so
you can't really pull that into
into this actual application
i'm desperately trying to think of ways
or
work out ways how i could go against the
officers
on this one but i don't think i'm going
to be able to
but those are my initial thoughts i'll
throw it out there for everyone else to
to to put their two pence worth in
lovely thank you very much uh councillor
crump next
um i was starting to agree with quite a
bit that
character jennings actually said
until he came to the big butt um i don't
think there is the big butt on this one
um previously tonight we've approved
applications
that didn't have community support far
from it in several cases
um and now we've got an application in
it's got strong community support
from 14 neighbours
uh well 14 letters to support it might
not be 14 neighbors and it might not be
14 different households so i slightly
apologize for that erin but there's been
14 letters of support
the parish council supports it the uh
warden under supports it so um
and just going back to cancer jennings's
point about
we don't know about the background or
the history of that site or the office
or the
prefabricated buildings but this is
where we rely on local knowledge
of the people of the the parish council
of the
people who are actually supporting the
application and also
the ward members so if fast then it's in
there in the confines of the the builder
confines of the
uh in the physical compounds of the
settlement in their opinion
and i think it was the agent of our
member who said again it's a judgment
call
i would be willing to accept them and i
would be actually
proposing that we grant this application
okay lovely thank you very much
councillor crump councillor mills is
next
please counselor mills yeah yeah thanks
mr chairman and actually i'm
sort of echoed up
this is surrounded by you you've got a
quarry very close by you've got a
a a a business opposite
and and it's backing on to you know
not very pleasant looking buildings i
can't see the harm for this to be honest
i really can't
uh so um i will be going against
officer's recommendations chairman thank
is you a formal seconding of councillor
trump's uh proposal
did he propose it yes i'll second him
then stop man good stuff thank you very
much cancer dixon next
uh thank you chairman uh council mills
just beat me to second ignite because
essentially it's to my mind it's
how do we interpret the confines of the
village it is a judgement call
i'm satisfied it's close enough
okay thank you very much um i can see no
one else indicating their desire to chat
decide to chat sorry desire to speak um
i do want to speak to
uh planning manager first of all though
um and to check that you're satisfied
with the reasons to go against the
officer's recommendation as they've been
presented
um david could you help me out there
please
yes thank thanks chair from my
understanding of the debate
um and the proposal i i understand that
it's
uh uh recommended to uh approve this
application on the basis that members
consider it is
uh reasonably adjacent to the physical
confines
of um edge hill and in that respect
complies with
the requirements of the core strategy um
there is a slight nuance to this as well
as um
uh requiring the usual planning
conditions because
of the description of the development
and the type of application that's been
made here
the resolution from the council if it
were to approve this or to
to resolve to approve this needs to be a
resolution to approve this subject to a
section 106.
um so we would need to resolve to
approve it subject to a section 106
which secured
this as a local needs property but also
secured it as a self
build property as that forms the basis
of
the locational acceptability of the
um i think uh
at that point it would probably be best
turnover again to you
chair if if you wanted to invite any
further debate
uh please do so but please could i ask
if you came back to the case officer
myself for conditions
before proceeding to a vote on the
resolution thanks
okay no problem i can see council mills
has indicated his desire to speak so
we'll hear from him before we do that
please say councilman yeah thanks for
the chairman uh yes
uh okay we've got this they've applied
for one
uh dwelling um
is there a condition you put on it yes
it's just for one dwelling on this
on this side because we hear about
developers taking liberties i don't want
anybody else to be
so it can a condition be put on only one
i think i think we can um given
that is the uh it is for
a single self build local market
dwelling that is the application so
um i think it in itself it is already
limited to one that was being applied
for but i get your sentiment
um castle jennings has indicated his
desire to speak so i'll get him to come
in now before we come back to our planet
yeah
oh sorry officer so one of
i thought then as they're talking about
the need to look after the horses could
it
could have been agricultural tied to it
i don't know i know nothing about
agricultural ties but
um i think even
given that um they haven't applied for
an agricultural tie
um i i think it would be i'm sure um
i'm sure our planning manager will tell
me otherwise um if i'm getting this
wrong but
um it feels to me like we might be
making a material change to the
application as it was submitted
uh if we were to do that um yeah you've
got no one else
indicated what i'm going to suggest is
david if you could respond to that last
comment that i've just made but also if
you could talk to
us about any of the conditions that you
would expect to be there and then we can
fit in any gaps that we might think
that needs to be added yeah absolutely
chair
i think you're spot on in respect to
that i think there's no need to tie
it um as an agricultural dwelling that's
not what's been applied for
or what members have considered here
there would be a need to tie it as a
self-build dwelling
and as a local needs dwelling in
perpetuity
um and that's what the purpose of the
the section 106 would achieve
um i think i hope to invite erin at this
point to
to recommend um a number of uh
conditions that members might wish to
consider adding to their
um recommendation their resolution sorry
sure
thank you so in terms of um in addition
to the legal agreement
we'll be looking at a number of standard
conditions including three years
for material commencement approved plans
materials prior to slab level
hard and soft landscaping foul and
surface water drainage
we've also got two conditions
recommended by environmental health one
for contamination and one for
remediation works
recontamination and then we've just got
water vets
electric vehicle charging points bins um
ecology condition as well to tie in the
measures that are in place on the
drawings
and a condition to tie in renewable
energy technologies that are proposed on
the drawings as well
um and three notes the mppf a note about
the legal agreement
and fire and rescue have also
recommended a note as well so i'd look
to
recommend that note as well
okay i'm i'm satisfied with those um i
forget now he proposed this i think it
was councillor crump council crumb are
you happy with those conditions
yeah more than happy mr chairman thank
you you don't want to have any
no i think no i think that's why i look
up
i thought they were quite comprehensive
and getting like so the brain's
beginning to go i'm afraid
that's right no worries um counselor
mills i presume you're happy uh with
those and you don't want to add anything
oh yes mr chairman i
can't think of anything at the moment
thank you lovely stuff okay in that case
uh we have no one else indicated uh
their desire to speak
so um let's move we have a proposal
it is to grant subject to the 106 um
and with all the conditions as they have
been laid out by aaron just now
um we will go straight to the vote i
think uh cancer issues first
uh four thank you
councillor fleming occasionally four
councillor kendall councillor kendall
four
seraphin
councillor jennings i'll put my gut away
for
councillor mills councillor mills for
thank you very much for that okay so
committee therefore resolves to grant
uh application twenty zero two four
three nine four landed jason two
romney's rest in edge hill subject to
one assist in the conditions that we've
just laid out
fabulous thank you very much everyone
for that let's move to our live thank
you committee for
for that thank you very much i will
leave you in peace
thanks john um so we'll move to our last
item now
uh three minutes before the cutoff
twenty 20 02 856 ful which is 17 oxford
street in southern our presenting
officers paul thompson
paul are you there i hope you are hi i'm
indeed counsellor thank you
thanks chair happy new year to one and
all i shall try and run through this as
quickly as possible so we can all
get to bed um
you should shortly be able to see
my screen is that coming up for everyone
that is yeah thank you stuff okay we are
here
in southern it's on oxford road in salem
um
this is the site it's uh comprises an
existing house
at the front of the site uh along with
um some redundant um
industrial commercial buildings to the
to the rear it's a resubmission
of uh a scheme that the scheme of five
dwellings that the
uh committee this committee refused a
couple of years ago
that refusal went to appeal
and the refusal was upheld
so the reason for refusal was that
that scheme which you can see here uh
included the room the demolition of the
existing house
which would have been about there and
it's replacement with the terrace of
three
dwellings here as you can see there's
also two further semi semi-detached
pair of houses at the back of the site
as you can see from the current
site plan which is before you now the
existing house is to be retained
and we're left with the pair of semis at
the back
as a result of the existing house being
retained um
the access has moved from the existing
driveway
to the other side of the house which is
here
the scheme is otherwise unchanged so the
two houses themselves haven't changed
this shows the uh fairly um severe
topography
at least by villages village center
standards um
you've got the houses at the bottom here
looking up over the site
this is the existing house here which is
roughly level with the the other houses
on oxford road um
this is the um elevations
these are the elevations um fairly
standard design
these are the floor plans both three bed
houses with a home office
above as a view into the site from
roughly the the uh somewhere along where
the new access will go
uh this is a view up towards the
existing house which you can just see
at the top this is a view towards the
access showing the existing house the
the access the new access will be
around where this shrub is here
and finally this is the view from the
access towards the uh
fairly sharp bend in the oxford road um
the sole reason for the um
dismissal of the previous appeal was
that the
um existing the loss of the existing
dwelling would be harmful to the street
scene and the conservation area
as the existing dwelling is now to be
retained
my recommendation is the grant planning
commission there are no other grounds as
i see it
to refuse thank you chair over to you
paul thank you very much um for that and
we will move straight
to our speakers if we can so counselor
andrew wolster
southern parish council uh councillor
walster are you there can you hear me
you may need to press star on six to unm
your phone thank you chair if you can
hear me i certainly can
um you have three minutes i think you've
probably got the drill by now three
minutes 30 seconds
whenever you're ready do start thank you
good evening committee
um we 17 oxford street has got a
fairly considerable planning history
which your officer has been through
already
there were three original points of
objection from the town council
grounds of flooding highways and the
historic environmental
and heritage asset of the actual
original number 17
oxford street the reduction to two new
dwellings is welcomed as is the
interaction between the town council and
the developer throughout the
throughout the process town council also
clear that development is needed on this
site to clean up
the former semi-industrial site that you
have seen on the pictures presented by
your officer
the officers report deals with both the
flooding and highways
issues and these have also been
considered by the inspector
and not to be supported for reasons for
refusal
therefore the remaining concern for 17
oxford street
is the can is the commit is any
commitment
to the renovation and reuse and being
brought back into use
of 17 oxford street at the moment we
have no particular commitment from the
developer
or any um condition which would allow
this to be
allow this to be brought forward with
some confidence that the town council
could then
remove its objection down to no
representation
therefore what the town council are
looking for is a commitment from the
developer and
or a condition
that the developer agrees to that along
with the
new develop new dwellings at the back of
the development that the
existing historical asset is brought
back into use as a house
on the front of oxford street retaining
that for the street scene and the
heritage asset within the conservation
area
thank you chad marvellous thank you very
much councillor
and i will see if our members have any
questions for you
so members do you have any questions for
our
uh parish council please indicate the
chat if you do
council mills is first up councilman
thanks mr chairman um oh good evening
uh councillor there's been
quite a few comments about flooding um
uh could could you enlighten me on that
is that because of water run off or it
can't it's not because of a stream is it
or
underground stream or anything like that
is it just purely because of the um
um the lowness if you like of the um
where it's situated so if the officer
could go back to the
picture with the cross section showing
the new dwellings at the bottom of the
site and the 17 oxford street at the top
of the side it'd be quite useful
at the bottom left of that drawing
is is the river that runs through
southam and it has
the area is in a has been considered by
the environment agency as a flooding
area
they are comfortable with what is in the
development therefore
we felt we have no grounds for objection
from flooding because the environment
agency are happy with it from that point
of view
okay thank you lovely thank you um
members do you have any further
questions for council worldstar
please get in the chat if you do
i'm seeing very little action at the
moment councilworld thank you very much
for your contribution uh you're probably
best served
to continue to watch the live stream and
hang up your handset now but thank you
once again for your contribution this
evening
thank you okay let's move to our next
speaker who
is victoria bainen um spain and are you
there you may need to press star on 61
mute yourself
i heard you briefly and i think you then
muted again
oh sorry okay we've got you now
thank you hi i think you've worked out
the drill now three minutes 30 second
warning uh questions afterwards
whenever you're ready do feel free to
start all right lovely thank you
um i'm victoria vayner good evening all
i live directly next door to number 17
at 16 a
um we're neighbors we're obviously very
worried about the proposal
it's been going on for some time and
there's a lot of reasons we're against
it there's
the first thing the flooding um i
appreciate what's already been stated
um but the environment agency master
planning actually shows the proposed
land to be in flood zone
two and three we've recently had floods
that the water was really high
the core strategy states that important
development doesn't result in flooding
or increase the risk downstream which
this would certainly do
um another aspect which is privacy once
it's cleared the groundwork
building will be two metres minimum
higher than the existing gardens meaning
privacy and light is going to be very
compromised in neighbouring houses
not just in oxford street but bambi road
willow gardens
i feel this type of background
development on this side and scale very
intrusive and sympathetic to the current
dwelling and the neighbouring properties
and important to note we are in a
conservation area the change to the
street scene will be huge and i'll
prepare the photographs that i've
provided if you actually stand opposite
you can clearly see how visible the
houses will be from the road
the nature of their appearance alone
should be enough to refuse the
application as it was before we're in a
conservation area and we're trying to
preserve the heritage that we've got
the core strategy states any development
should enhance the characteristic of the
market town and this doesn't
the impact on the two houses is
widespread and unnecessary and we feel
far outweighs the per the public benefit
that this scheme would bring
um very important for us to note which
is something i would like everyone to
to focus on that this proposal mentioned
nothing about the property at the front
um the developers conceded that he won't
um demolish it at present but
considering the state of it and the work
needed i find it really puzzling that he
wants to subject the house to another
winter empty with no plans to restore it
and if i was cynical i'd suggest maybe
he wishes to obtain planning for the new
properties while further neglecting 17
and at a later date perhaps explore yes
again the demolition of this house in
favour
of another inappropriate and insensitive
scheme and replacement so i would
implore the council to please impose a
caveat on any planning that they're
minded to approve
that the current dwelling is to be
improved and restored concurrently with
any new dwellings
access is a huge issue for us the
proposal of provision for nine cars on
the plot
is is to be is a huge over development
of the site in our opinion
the driveway's actually been moved even
closer to the blind bend at a four-way
junction and it will see over nine times
the current flow of traffic being passed
in and out
there are upwards also to note there
have been upwards of a thousand houses
built in our local area in southern and
surrounding villages since the data that
the highways used to make
their decision was collated so i can't
see this is a fair reflection
boundaries is a huge issue for us we
raised that concern important to note
along with councillors who previously
visited the site from the committee
both ourselves and our neighbour at 16
share boundaries with 17
and it's actually the outbuildings at
number 17 which are proposed to be
demolished that form the boundaries of
earthens and
number 16. it's been the case for many
many
years and at number 16 the wall that
forms the boundary
her garden wall is actually one of the
outbuildings
the wall is integral to the composition
of the garden and the demoli
the demolition of this wall would result
in a lack of boundary
and frankly a proposed concrete sense um
which has been suggested isn't
satisfactory it's not sensitive to the
setting and it's not appropriate for
conservation area
so we would urge councillors to object
to the scheme respectfully once again in
respect of our heritage
and of the site and the conservation
values thank you
thank you very much for that um members
do we have any questions
for victoria branan please mrs maynard
please indicate in the chat if you do
read a little action happening at the
moment
it looks like there'll be no questions
for you
no okay um miss venom thank you very
much for your contribution this evening
um as with other speakers you're best
served now to watch uh on the live
stream
and to hang up your handset but thank
you again for your contribution
okay thank you so much thank
um you we move to our next speaker i
just does this
both the parish council and um our
resident objector
have uh suggested a condition that would
ensure
the um the vacant building is put back
into
use before we move to our um agent
uh it's possible that question can be
put to him i want to find out from our
planning
manager whether that is possible i don't
believe it
is possible i don't think it would be
right to do so but i want to check with
you whether that in your opinion is
is correct or whether we would be in a
position to do that no in
in my opinion unfortunately such
condition wouldn't meet the tests
that are required of it by the nppf it
wouldn't be reasonable or necessary to
to do that for this development to be
acceptable
fortunately in in some respects
buildings within conservation areas are
protected from from demolition so any
future application for the use of that
building will
come before your officers in this
committee if necessary
of course lovely thank you i thought
that might be the case but thank you for
clarifying
okay in that case let's move to our
agent now uh mr steve bromley
uh mr romney are you there can you hear
me
star six one mute yourself
mr bromley hopefully you can hear me i
can see you dialed in if you press star
on six that should unmute you and we
should be able to hear you
hi chairman hello hello can you hear me
we can indeed yes welcome good evening
thank you chairman
thank you very much thank you um before
you begin
uh just so you know you've got six
minutes uh to speak
we will give you a thirty second warning
uh use as much or as little as the six
minutes as you wish but whenever you're
ready to start please do
yeah thank you chairman um the
application site comprises
previously developed brownfield land
within the built up area boundary of
southern just a few minutes walking
distance to the town
centre the previous application in 2018
and subsequent appeal
proposed demolition of all the buildings
on site and the construction of five
dwellings
the planning inspector found all aspects
of the proposals acceptable
aside from the loss of the existing
dwelling where he considered the
impact on the conservation era area to
be less than substantial
the two dwelling subjects of this
application are identical in sighting
scale and design to those proposed in
the 2018 application
and which were found by the planning
inspector in 2019
to be well designed sensitive to the
conservation area
subservient in scale owing to their
setback from the road and fall of the
land
and acceptable in all regards the
proposals incorporate
an extensive range of climate change
mitigation measures
including air source heat pumps electric
vehicle charging points
cycle storage sheds tree planting
garden sensory areas permeable paving
and bat and bird nesting boxes
the proposed new access has been through
a thorough assessment including
pre-application discussions with
washington county council
an independent road safety audit
together with a response report
and an access appraisal submitted with
the application
the hive authority has advised in their
formal consultation response
that they have no objection to the
proposals
the proposals comply with the council
standards for garden sizes
parking provision and separation
distances
therefore thereby providing satisfactory
amenities
for both the future occupiers of the
development and the amenities of
neighbours
chairman there are no objections from
the technical consorties including
as already stated the highway authority
and also no objection from the
environment agency
wcc ecology wcc
fine rescue and sdc waste and recycling
i asked the committee to support the
office's recommendation
and grant planning permission thank you
chairman
thank you very much mr bromley well
within your six minutes members do we
have any questions
for our agent this evening please
indicate the chat now if you do
give you a couple of seconds to do that
i'm not seeing much movement
that looks like it's going to be a no uh
mr romney thank you very much for your
contribution this evening you're
again your best place to continue to
watch the live stream on your computer
you can hang up your handset now but
thank you again for your contribution
thank you german thank you
thank you okay let's move now
to our final speaker of the evening
councillor
crump councillor crump you've
disappeared from my screen hopefully
you're still there
i'm here you are indeed you know the
drill five minutes 30 seconds
start when you're ready thank you chris
mr chairman trying to be a brief as
possible um
i did chuckle when you mentioned live
streaming and then
talk about rivers which was quite quite
quite funny
um but yeah one thing i'd like to start
off with i wasn't going to originally
talk about this but mr jeffrey mentioned
the fact about
safeguarding buildings in conservation
areas
and i know it's talked about on page 75
and mr thompson's report about
paragraph one of the mpf but
2018 i'll just reflect to remind
everybody of the fact that
the proposal proposed recommendation
from
officers was actual demolition of the
property
um so i'm not sure how much weight we
have protection there but i'll just make
that point because i think that's a
really important point
um so i i think we need to answer the
count and i'm not sure i'm sure mr
jeffrey might come back on that
um i'm sure caster pai will
recommend uh recognize this application
society she's been out there a couple of
times on site visits
and i would say this is the third
application over the past few years for
this site
two previous applications for five
properties
the existing traditionally proportioned
property incessant
conservation area the first application
was recommended for refusal
was the second application was
recommended for for granting
but it was turned down by committee and
the subsequent appeal was lost
and again i think it seems to mirror
some of the previous applications today
and i think uh council o'donnell stated
planning approval by
by submission so um i don't know is it
deja vu
um it's just certainly an improvement on
the previous application
um particularly with the numbers uh
regard
and of two new houses compared to five
and obviously it's a previously
developed site so it has some merits to
audit
i do have concerns and local residents
that have concerns
about highway safety but uh according to
um
otherwise that they can be overcome but
i i still
still have concerns and the same applies
with the flooding issues and again
the experts are saying there is not a
problem uh despite evidence
that's shown by one of the objectives
earlier
um my main concern about this one is
guaranteeing the future of this this
traditional
uh property in the southern conservation
area um
i do think we still you know i've been
told of other cases
and um authorities not too far away from
us but
a condition was put in uh safeguarding
uh
the property or a similar property but i
was done to be corrected and obviously
uh by by our officers on that
so i would like to see some form of
um safeguarding of this property is that
as an accountant
i like to be an error on the side of
caution to be prudent
and have some reassurance that this
property will be maintained
and i'm pleased to say paul did slightly
reassure me on on page 1775
paragraph 191 the nwpf
so yeah i am i'm concerned about it
at the very least i would like it noted
or for some form of noting in the
minutes that
this point was raised um that
the safeguarding of the asset uh
which instructs decision makers to
disregard the deteriorated state of a
heritage issue where the state is the
result of deliberate harm or neglect
should an application be submitted in
future dimension replace the existing
house this would be
material consideration determination so
if that could be noted
and again from a practical point of view
and disruption point of view
um it would make sense from the
construction point of view on that busy
a423 road that was once the higher trunk
road between
cobb and branbury um that
it was all done at the same time there'd
only be one lot of disruption
and obviously southern at the moment is
suffering substantial disruption from
our friends at hs2 we should close off
the a425 so
um i think we have suffered quite a bit
so that's all i like to say and ask
for the reasons i've just mended that
this application
is refused thank you council crm thank
you very much for that
um let's see if we have any questions
for you members do you have any
questions for our ward member please
indicate in the chat if you
do
just give a couple of seconds i can see
a few people moving around but i'm not
sure if they're typing
a couple more seconds
looks like that's a no so council trump
thank you very much
for your uh your contributions your help
this evening um let us move then
to uh points for clarification for our
offices uh members do you have any
questions for
me looks like people were typing in
preparation for that counselor parry
first of all
thank you chair um yes my my question it
was
it was raised by the objector um and
council trump is quite right
i've been to the site on numerous
occasions um
so i can actually remember it quite well
one of the
objectors um neighbors
and having been in the garden i can
understand
the concern about um
her boundary wall is is like part of one
of the
one of the buildings can the it was very
difficult to sort of
see how that boundary would be
addressed and i just wonder whether the
officer can explain
if if in in the demolition of one of the
old buildings that forms part of the
the garden wall which has got some
heritage
and actually you know is
it i mean it would would totally
decimate
the whole of the neighbor's garden if
that wall was removed
i just would like some clarification on
how
that would be dealt with if they're
removing the the building
adjacent that's that's that's part of
the wall to the neighbor's wall
can you graduate glad you asked actually
i was um
sorry thank you
um um yeah
the um the wall in question um i've been
alerted to it
and we saw it briefly in the speaker's
photos
and that's something we can address with
the landscape scheme to a certain extent
we can specify that that boundary be
retained in its current form um
it may require some shoring up or other
works which again
can form part of that scheme the
neighbor will also have
some rights under the party wall act um
and potentially building regulations
although i expect not
um which wouldn't be within our arena
but um would afford them some protection
so
i i'm i'm confident that we can preserve
preserve that with an appropriately
worded landscape scheme condition
which for example would um prevent
any demolition works affecting that wall
taking place before
a scheme has been submitted for its
retention
casper you've got to follow up i can
just yeah if i can just
come back on that um
i think it's really it is really
important
that that wall that that wall
and the character because that that
would have huge impact
on the the character and the residential
and the
uh amenity of the neighboring property
if that wall was removed in you know
and and you know so i i can't emphasize
the importance of that
if we are minded to approve
okay uh i don't know if there's any need
for paul to come back on that or not
um we do have a question from uh
councillor jennings for you as well paul
if you if you
if you would say council jennings yeah
thank you thank you chairman
so i just want absolute clarity on this
um
there's no way we can um put put um
any conditions on the number 17 is
renovated or
so it's totally irrelevant to this
planning application
and that's correct council yes that's
great
that's all i need all right okay good
those are the questions and answers i
like uh councilman mills next
please thanks mr chairman yes it was
really follow-on for man um paul can you
put the
the photograph up showing this wall i
mean it was in that you
you got it there haven't you somewhere
yeah bear with me just a second
counselor
[Music]
will be do you do
you see that uh no i couldn't
that's can't see any photographs at the
moment no if you click on
one of the uh try again
there we are that should now be on your
screen
ah right okay so uh
i that's interesting as well but yeah so
this as i understand it is the the other
side of the wall
here so as you can see it's got a lot of
um
a lot of uh vegetation growing up in it
it's obviously a very
important part of the garden um it's not
wasn't clear altogether clear to me how
much of that form part of a
an adjoining building and how much it
was just the boundary wall
um so it either either way we can
we can use the the landscape scheme
condition to ensure that it's it's
retained
um and shored up where necessary um
but it will obviously be easier or
harder to do that depending on
which part of the wall is which of
course that that would massively affect
the neighbor of that
yeah absolutely absolutely counselor and
and i fully
um take that on board i i definitely
agree that we we should be retaining
that
okay thank you very much paul thank you
thanks counselor okay
good okay i'm gonna ask members again if
they have any further questions
and points of clarification to indicate
now otherwise we're going to move into
debate
give you a couple of seconds
that looks like a no so let's move into
debate who would like to kick us off
don't all jump at once
counselor jennings
right um this one
so there's nothing we can do about
number 17
um apart from if it does come to
committee at all in the future
we vote against it it's as simple as
that
um apart from that i don't see how we
can go against the officer's decision on
this obviously
if we put in any conditions of the on
the garden side just to make sure
not that will come in the landscaping so
um i think we've got no choice but to uh
to go ahead and grant this application
so i'd like to
propose that we do so thank you very
much councillor jennings
i would say that any future applications
don't necessarily uh won't necessarily
get voted against uh we will obviously
make our decisions based on what is
presented in front of us i wouldn't want
anyone to predetermine before anything's
even submitted
absolutely good um counselor dixon next
please
thank you chairman i'm happy to second
that proposal
good man councillor mills please
yes uh yes thanks mr chairman i yeah i
can't see how we can go against
uh office recommendation but uh just to
make sure we do retain that wall
thank you yeah i think that will be
retained as we've heard through the uh
conditions for landscaping um
uh perhaps we can have that as a note
on the i'm trying to have a look at the
notes now um
i tell you what i'm gonna ask uh cancer
jennings you proposed are you happy to
add it as a note
to ensure the uh the wall is covered
throughout the landscape
i am indeed good man uh councillor dixon
nice email that you're going to say yes
yes good stuff okay um councillor
kendall has indicated his desire to
second that has already been done
uh cancer council do you want to speak
at all yeah chair just to say i
completely agree with what's been said
in terms of proposing this
it looks to me like the applicants have
gone a long way to listen to what
this committee has said and i can find
no reason not to go with it
thank you very much councillor kendall i
couldn't agree more um i will therefore
move to a the vote in that case
uh and i will start council the proposal
is to uh grant
uh application twenty zero two eight
five six ful 17 oxford street
in line with offers a recommendation
with the addition of a note to ensure
um the boundary wall treatment is dealt
with through the landscaping plan
um or the landscaping condition i should
say council richards
four thank you cancer fleming
cancer flowing four councillor kendall
councillor kendall four dickson
councillor dixon four select edin
council red and four
[Music]
that's okay councillor parry four that's
unanimous chair
marvelous thank you very much olivia and
members um committee therefore resolves
to grant application twenty zero two
eight five six full seventeen office
retreat in southern
um uh in line with officer
recommendation and with the addition of
that note
members there being no urgent business
uh we can draw the uh
tonight's committee to a close thank you
all very much for your uh time and
patience this evening
both to members particularly to officers
for the work they've done behind the
scenes to make sure tonight runs as
smoothly as it did
and to all of our speakers happy new
year to everyone
and we'll see you in a couple weeks